e
e e
we will get started in a few minutes I
mean hopefully the chairman will arrive
but if to get started you know he's
running late and I nearly ran late
myself pre appreciate your P so we'll
probably another two or three minutes
and then get
started
e
e e
I think I'm going to get started uh with
this it's it's a work session anyway and
the chairman should be here shortly but
I know do is here so I think we should
get started so let's open up uh this
work session on house build uh 20
2024 and I I think I don't know if we
have questions or if do wants to start
with some information please come up uh
for those the officials who are um
giving us some more
information okay welcome back gentlemen
Mr rodrig and Mr oldenberg correct
correct okay good I got your name is
correct okay thank you very much I mean
if you want to get started and then I'll
open up to questions please I will do
that so uh in front of you should be a
packet uh we put it in the form of a
presentation but it's really uh a list
of answers to the questions that that
you folks had um at the at the last uh
work session um last week and also a
list of uh project amendments which is a
blue sheet double-sided single sheet um
and we'll talk about those in a few
minutes so
um do this the same way uh we did last
time so on slide one these were the the
discussion items uh that we heard from
from the last work session
um as and as part of the uh the the the
public hearing that we had uh questions
that came out so um on page two and
three was a list of
acronyms um so we it's the magic decoder
ring of what all these terms mean uh
that we just spew out uh un realizing
that most people don't know what they
mean so this is a a list of uh the
different uh acronyms that we use uh in
the the last presentation uh and in this
one as well split it out between uh
different entities different groups uh
some miscellaneous and then on sheet
three is sort of what all the funding
sources mean and the abbreviations
associated with the funding
sources
um and I would I would if you have any
questions along the way there's usually
just like one or two slides per topic so
if you have any questions okay you're
right with answer questions as you go on
okay thank you very much Mr oldberg so
we are now okay you've done p on page
four you're on page four now so is
everybody okay so far with through p uh
up to page four all right no questions a
moment okay please continue gentlemen
all right um discretionary grants we had
some questions about what discretionary
grants uh are available um who's
received the grants uh either
communities or the state and what we've
applied for um so on page four we have a
list of of some of these grants that um
are new to the
iig and um or renewed um maybe rebranded
uh from previous versions um these These
are broken out and you'll see that
different
communities either either communities or
mpos or the state can apply for these
but not every single one so you take the
second one down safe routes and roads
for all or I'm sorry the third one down
um only a community or an Mo can apply a
state can't apply for those grants so
there's different flavors of grants for
different things and also there's
different restrictions on who can apply
for these grants and we excuse me Mr
okay a question on safe Street say
Sullivan County is it can you give me an
idea what for what streets is that the
they for in solivan county in case I'm
asked it by constituents
that's a good question I I don't know we
can get you we can get you that
information so the way these grants
typically work um so we do not budget
for these in the 10year plan so unless
we receive a grant then we'll put it in
the 10year plan so we do not budget for
receiving grants until we actually get
them okay U because we have no idea um
how successful will'll be so okay um and
I just put we put a note in there that
um 30 36% of the iig funding or $900
billion um is a is under discretionary
grants um and that's just the Federal
Highway portion there's a small portion
of grants that are available through FDA
FAA F Etc so that's just the Federal
Highway portion on on page five is
a uh yes go ahead please representive
alone thank you Mr chairman um so on all
the discretionary
grants this is just a listing of what's
available correct correct follow up okay
please continue
so do you track how many of these grants
have been applied for by communities in
the states I mean are you keeping a list
of what's I mean how do we how do we
know how much money of this of from all
these programs is coming into New
Hampshire I guess basically that's much
so we'll go to the next next page so um
one thing I would say is this is not a
complete list list this is just a list
of the grants that are available to New
Hampshire typically there are other
grants that are available for like
tunnels um fairies um uh Native American
populations so there's also very
specified grants that that New Hampshire
either doesn't qualify for or or
wouldn't have a purpose to apply for so
we just listed the ones there are much
more um so on page five is is the L
listing of discretionary grants that we
know um we've we've we've received as a
state so when you see like the very
first one Safe Streets for all um as I
said those are either Community or
Mo um Municipal planning organizations
the
RPC those the only folks that can apply
the state can't so all of these were
applied for by a
community um and were received you'll
notice the words at the top that a
direct recipient right next to Safe
roots to school that means that those
communities or that that applicant
receives the money directly from Federal
Highway we are not involved so why I
don't know what roads in Sullivan County
because we didn't have anything to do
with the application we we haven't been
involved we can get that information
okay um but when you see direct
recipient that means the money goes
directly to the communities from Federal
Highway and the do isn't involved in
tracking those all right great thank you
for that clarification ification yes
represent Mills please so in this in
this instance when the when we've got
the direct recipients and they get this
money for this project city of Keane
$350,000 that goes direct to them will
that project ever show up in the 10-year
plan or is it up to them to build it or
is it up to them to contact you to say
we need this done we've got the money
we're going to pay for it how does that
work no the the town is the town would
either hire hire someone to design the
um and and put it out to bid and have it
built we wouldn't we wouldn't typically
be involved and they would they wouldn't
ask for our assistance okay that that's
just for the direct recipient cor I
suppose the other ones are going to be
exceptions no doubt correct so you'll
see in the middle of the page the
general Sullivan Bridge okay we received
a a $20 million raise Grant um so that
is our project that money came to us and
that would show in the 10-year plan is
under the funding's $20 million of of
raise
Grant and that's the same for Hinsdale
Brattleboro and the leban and Harford
project so the last three on the page
are our state DOT projects where we
received the funds we applied we
received the funds and we would without
showing the 10-year
plan on page six um there's another uh a
do project which is aquatic organism
passage uh another grant that the city
of do applied for and received direct
recipient all the rest are congressional
directed spending funds
so these are uh Congressional um
delegation applied for put in for these
communities and these were received
these are LPA projects so we will manage
these to some degree we'll we'll we will
pass through the funding either the
community will manage it or we
will um so you'll see the a total Grant
Awards currently 980 million or sorry
that's one too many zeros in there n98
million um has been awarded uh
currently on page seven
is an ongoing list that we keep of
grants that the dot has applied for um
these are iiga
grants um they're they're split out into
the the first two are grants that were
awarded so we applied for these grants
we received
um uh funds for those grants and so you
see what the project cost is what the
grant amount requested was the date we
received uh
a positive uh Award of the Grant and
then how much we received the middle are
grants that we've applied
for um that are pending outcome so we
don't know whether we've received the
grants or not and then at the bottom the
last three were grants that we applied
for that we were unsuccessful and did
not
receive so this is an ongoing list
changes it sort of gives you a flavor of
the different Grant types that uh We've
applied for
uh for different project types as well
so we actively look uh for grants that
are available projects that we could
apply for that that meet the criteria
and are actively um looking to apply for
these
grants right thank you please continue
see any questions
questions so the the next question on
page eight um dealt with historic p
so this was a a request of how many
miles have we historically paved
um and this is a a chart that goes back
to
1992 so you'll see that in the 2000s uh
the paving um went down
considerably in
200 10ish you'll see we paved 700 miles
that was an ARA Spike American Recovery
and I'll forget the other our act so
federal government gave us lots of money
we used it to pave the roads and bring
the conditions
up that's why there was that spike it
was really a one onetime
um uh effort um and
funding then you'll see um the
next in the next couple years it goes
back to you know the prear era of of
about 300 miles a year and then there's
a spike again in
2014 and that is directly related to S
SP
367 um and that influx of funds uh to be
able to pave roads so that roughly say
$20 million um that was directly related
to our ability to pave more than 500
Miles um there's a a little dip in
21 um directly related to
covid and and um I contractors not not
pay
Mees um and then you'll see where we are
currently so that you know from
2014 uh to date um the being able to pay
over 400 miles a year directly related
to the S SP 367
funds uh uh yes uh okay yes we have a
question ref on Boger
please um based on your chart here in 20
22 where you had a dip um of that and if
we had the same amount of money coming
from that uh other bill that SB Bill uh
did we save that money to move it
forward or what did we do with that
money yeah I I think what you see is the
the the 300
and 37 it's tough getting old 33 337 I
should have put these on earlier hey
it's
um what you see is the there's probably
100 miles in there we didn't pave we
paved it the next year that's why 515 is
a little higher than the rest so um the
reality is is that the paving we didn't
do in 21 we we did in
22 oh yes fall please continue rest the
money that was not
spent because you said usually there's
enough money from that bill to pay 500
and if we're Paving 300 add a couple
million dollars a mile does that yeah so
so we we
didn't we used the money we just used it
the next year so the difference the the
337 we we probably we didn't pave um
mainly either the construction Crews
weren't working because of covid or
couldn't work because of covid so that
we didn't PVE the full call it you know
450 miles we pave 337 so the the the
projects that we didn't pave in
22 or in 21 we paved in 23 so that's why
we have 500 miles in 20 uh
2022 we didn't lose money we didn't save
money we just use the money the next
year all
right if I may just to add a little bit
of color to that we do bring the money
forward but what we are seeing as prices
increase we are Paving fewer and fewer
miles so there's two dynamics that that
are impacting us one we saved the money
from
2021 because of covid and then as we put
that money back to work we're not
getting quite as many miles out of it
because the costs are are going up as
well thank you for that that makes a lot
more sense thank you thank you and
that's why you see the decrease from 500
miles down to where we are currently at
450 or so okay thank you representative
Boyd please thank you Mr chairman I know
you probably have said this my mind is
failing me right now how many how many
linear miles of Road are on by the
state we
have 40 4600 miles of state
roads follow Mr chair uh yes please
continue thank
you in looking at the historic Paving
over the last 32 years just appears to
me to be very
chaotic and having come from a municipal
background
where we've planned and graded our roads
so that we're able to analyze and figure
out what road gets paved next does the
dot employ a planning methodology that
gives the 4600 miles of Roads specific
grades and therefore prepares its roads
for when it needs to be repaved based on
the grade just curious curious to know
what you meod on absolutely we have a in
our materials and research section we
have a pavement management section it's
made up of a group of people this is all
they do every day so they review every
section of State Road they they we have
uh data machines that go out and measure
the runting and the roughness and um and
and develop a an index a rating index of
the condition of the road and we
prioritize those that are in foreign in
poor shape um develop a a plan for the
best um most cost efficient way of uh
bringing that road back into shape um
and this this group is uh exemplary in
in what they do um using the few dollars
that they have to bring the roads up and
I think the next slide you'll really see
the work that they've done over the last
10 years
um the the
top
okay there's another question okay yeah
I'm sorry yes please Contin sorry about
thank you appreciate
it I I saw this I I cheated I I I jumped
ahead um currently right now going into
2024 and I'm not sure what your grading
system is but what how many linear miles
of Road are graded let's just say C
minus are below and what's the cost
going to be to bring them back up to a b
or a
c is it on your slides because I haven't
so so on slide nine we basically use a
system of good Fair poor and very poor
okay then let me let me retract and
rephrase out of the 4600 linear miles
how many roads how many linear miles of
roads are currently classified as either
poor or very poor in the
state linear miles we're going to do
we're going to do math do math so so as
as he does the math let let me explain
what the two charts show on on in
2014 uh we basically had
33% or a third of those roads were in
poor very poor shape now through the
efforts of of our pavement management
section and you know the funding
received through
s367 um we're down to 14%
uh poor very poor and actually the very
poor roads have gone from 7 to 1%
so if if I may there that leaves about
644 miles but if if I could I would like
to take your point in totality
representative Boyd you you made the
observation that the mileage we pave is
somewhat chaotic so the mileage we pave
is a direct function of the funding that
we have and I understand that understand
that if if I can as funding increased in
2014 we've been able to to be somewhat
um consistent we are seeing that mileage
tailing off now and that mileage is TA
tailing off because the funding has
remained somewhat consistent but the
price has gone up I want to explain this
thoroughly because the bottom line when
it comes to funding we are facing as B
367 going away as we've explained so
we're out we're about to face one of
those those more chaotic um lines in
this graph where in 26 we won't be
Paving as many miles um because of that
loss of SB
367 what the Department's committed to
is to try to flex our our federal funds
to the extent that we can to keep our
payment and in good conditions but those
Federal funds are also committed to the
projects in the in the 10-year plan so
um we are again facing in the near
future loss of funding that will impact
our asset condition and our payment
condition so if if I if I
may one of the other things is the the
graphs the charts on the wall so the the
the chart on your left is the pavement
condition uh in tiers one and two and
then the the middle chart the the one on
the right there is pavement conditions
on tier three and four and you'll see
the color coding is the same so a little
bit deeper dive into the roads that we
see that are are say in very poor shape
the the green the all green gra uh bar
graph on the far left are the tier one
rows the interstates those are all in in
good or Fair shape there are no very
poor poor roads on the interstate system
and we dedicate funds to keep it that
way so the second graph of the tier 2
roads those are the route 16s the route
9s those major uh Statewide corridors um
that are high volume roads that we need
to keep in uh in good shape and you'll
see that very little of those are in in
poor shape um then when you get over
into the tier three and four roads
you'll see that the the poor and the
very poor increase and it's the tier
four roads the the bar graph on the
far right that have the the highest
those are those those unnumbered State
routes that a lot of people would say is
this really a state route those are the
ones that don't have a high traffic
volume that tend to be more
community-based roads that we don't we
don't have a lot of resources for and
most of those
roads I I will say are not federally
eligible and we talked about that last
time that 11 100 miles of the 4600
aren't federally eligible so the only
funds we you can use are State funds so
that's SP 367 and that that used to be a
huge number of poor and very poor roads
because we had no funds to really pave
those roads in
2014 so now we've been able to invest
that s SP 367 funds in those roads that
aren't F federally eligible so you you
see that those tier three and four roads
those Community Based roads are the ones
that were affected the most uh by that
that funding so
hopefully thank you Mr chairman
represent
sorry would you say that the uh 14% of
the roads that are poor and very poor
will consume a larger portion of that
that budgeted money because they're in
worse shape than if you were repairing
like the
31% uh which is in the fair condition
and stuff like that not typically I mean
we review each Road for for what pavment
treatment it is on a tier three or four
Road the typical treatment is either an
overlay um we may Mill out some of the
the the ruts or we may um may fill in
and and do what we call a drag shim we
would we would fill in with pavement
those ruts to smooth the road out and
then overlay it we have lowcost ways to
improve the roads and bring them out of
the very poor condition they are what
you tend to see is the more costly
improvements are those that are done on
the interstate or on those tier 2 roads
where we actually have to Mill out the
road because the the mill out the top
courses of Road Road bed because they're
they're they're failing um runting
Beyond savings so an overlay isn't going
to fix it and it's basically deals with
the high volume of traffic the high
heavy truck loads that we see on them
you know continually uh degrades the
pavement so you see those a lot more uh
more costly improvements on those bigger
roads but there's less miles of those
done each year so back representative
voy thank you Mr chairman duve tailing
off of Representative bogur because he
thank you for asking your question I
appre appreciate that you you talk about
how some of these are community
community based roads and the folks that
live in these communities have have a
right to drive a road without losing a
filling so and I don't mean to sound
crass I mean it's one thing to put patch
into the road it's another thing that
actually if we own if if the state owns
the road then that there should be a
specific level of care that's given to
that particular road so that people can
can use it to be able to get from point
point A to point B I mean I get the
funding piece because I wanted to rip up
my driveway in 2019 and it was going to
be 18 I went to look at it last year and
it is now 30 just to rip up my my
quarter mile driveway where I live in
Marram 18 to 30 within the span of a
couple of years so yes prices are going
up so the question I would ask is that
if prices are going up how how come a
request for an additional influx of
capital to to to rebuild these roads is
isn't being requested I think it's I
mean I sat on the Town Council for 10
years and I had DPW tell me it's going
to cost me this to do the roads we gave
it to them not not that I'm Cavalier
with the taxpayer at Dollar I'm just
saying that there's there's a there's
there's a price to to maintain these
roads so I'm just curious to know if
there's a plan to be asking for more
funding in the near future to to tackle
these these 1100 miles that aren't
eligible for f Federal funding
so I appreciate that that question
that's exactly what we are are doing
here having this this discussion so the
department does not necessarily take the
position of coming to house Public Works
and telling you we need more money and
we need you to provide us money what we
are here telling you is what we can do
with the funds that that we have and we
we trust you to recognize if if you
think we we need more funds and to work
with us through discussions to to help
to to get that um so I appreciate the
the question and the discussion and if
house Public Works wants to have a
bigger discussion about Revenue I think
the the department could is is in a
position to to have that discussion I
would like to make one more distinction
about the paving if if that's okay um
particularly when it comes to these tier
four roads which are our low volume
volume roads the condition of those
roads is very very important to us and
our current pavement strategy has us
providing what we call a maintenance
pave so to your question of is it more
expensive to rehabilitate those those
tier four roads if we were to
reconstruct those roads to the level
they need to be because many of them
have not been formally constructed we
would be talking about cost of a million
a half to maybe $2 million a mile for
some of those roads with our strategy of
Maintenance Paving we can treat those
roads on a regular cycle for 50 to
75,000 per per mile with with the
resources that we have and being good
stewards of the the taxpayer resources
as much as we the department would like
to reconstruct that that 800 plus miles
of of road we think right now and we
think our data proves it the best way to
keep those roads in good condition is to
continue to do this maintenance Paving
we continue to identify through our
districts the very worst of those roads
in do some more more deeper
reconstruction that we'd like to that
that we'd like to do and as necessary
but we do think we have a good balance
of the maintenance Paving versus the the
deeper
reconstruction thank you uh represent
Pon peon
bone Bon I'm sorry I have two spots on
these desks that I constantly pulled the
wrong way I apologize no problem
represent alone thank you Mr
chairman okay so I'm trying to figure
this out so what you're saying is you we
have a maintenance
plan to take care of these roads $50,000
dollars a
mile but there's still in very poor
condition what would it take to get that
number from 1% down to
zero that's one question the second
question is what would it take to
eliminate poor and very poor
roads I I can I can tell you if we're
talking about reconstructing 500 miles
of of very poor roads exceed from a
million to a million and a half per mile
it's going to cost 500 million to 550
Plus
million so I
I I think what you what you're seeing is
with these very poor roads is the the
the maintenance and preservation
treatment that we do is we we overlay it
right so typically we we'll put an an
inch of pavement on top and it keeps it
together we have a pavement cycle of
maybe eight eight or 10 years where we
come back the problem is those roads
hold together for
six
so they they fall into the very poor
shape and then a year or so later we
pave
them we really can't can't we don't have
the funds the ability the contractors to
be able to
pave these roads on a a a better cycle
than that I mean the reality is how do
we reduce this to zero um that's a
that's a tough one because I think we're
always going to have roads that are in
poor shape just mainly because we we
can't spend enough money pave enough
Lanes uh to take them out so this is not
the same road every year this is just
they move around and as the road
degrades and gets towards its cycle
it'll fall into the very poor shape it's
it's sort of like the roof on your house
you know it's supposed to last 30 years
well the last five years of it it's in
pretty sh tough shape and you question
whether or not you should replace it
well that's that's where we are with
some of these roads is you you look at
them and say and it's it's in tough
shape it needs to needs to be fixed um
and and then we usually get to it so
I I will
and so a story back in 2012
2014 we were up in the North Country I
think in the town of
Tamworth up with our district engineer
received tons of complaints about a road
the speed limit was meaningless because
you couldn't go more than 10 miles an
hour it was it was you know it was free
thaw spring mud season and the road was
terrible we would get calls all the time
about the conditions of the roads we do
not get calls about the conditions of
the roads anymore people understand that
we're going to get to them and and the
the condition I mean we've gone from a
third of our roads in poor shape to to
16% 86% of our roads are in good and
fair shape to me that's that's a that's
a tremendous achievement in in in my my
view and you know with the continued
funding and with our asset management
with our with our crew that goes out and
figures out the way to prioritize these
roads um we can we can do better um and
we can get that number down we think but
to get it to zero I'm not
sure I'm not sure we could really do
that I don't know if it would be
economical to be able to do that too
thank you um so a sidebar to your
sidebar where phones aren't ringing that
much anymore uh my phone rings I was in
Tuftonboro last night with the selectman
and a large group of uh people from town
asking me all the same questions these
representatives are and I was extremely
pleased that the department was able to
put me in contact with what our
reconstruction and our Paving schedule
was going forward for that town
extremely appreciate that or I would
have been tired and feathered leaving
that room what surprised the heck out of
me was when they saw that they're on um
that some of their roads they have they
have three of those and I can't tell you
which are tier three and tier four uh
171 109 and 109a they're horrible
anytime a year I drive over them the um
but when they saw that uh District 3 had
some resurfacing of 171 going out to bid
in 24 and they saw that it was at least
going to be considered and like the idea
of the department starting in sandwich
and running all the way to
Wakefield and that that in 25 and 26
might become a reality they said thank
you and and um so they they want to know
that they're on a schedule the the
biggest problem here is and I've had
phone calls from some of my uh favorite
colleagues in the Senate is what to
do um I believe Senate Bill 367 was was
the instrument that uh was tied to the
increase in the uh road toll and then uh
very creatively people other than us in
this this room had come up with that
schedule of um paying interest versus
principal and we ended up with this
wonderful thing that everyone started to
enjoy at 500 miles and then I was taken
back to here that I that we're back to
250 when I sat here when that first
passed I said you know we have years of
funding here and I can't imagine sitting
here when that runs out and I'm sitting
here when that's running out so I um we
were for the members that weren't here
when when this committee came out and
endorsed that road toll increase at Four
Cents
uh there were there were actual wanted
posters made and distributed online uh
for everyone that that was for that and
I think they put a King hat on everyone
that
wasn't uh we are we are at a point that
we need to be brave once again and I
don't know if it's if it's that's the
vehicle but I was just speaking to uh
represent Mills earlier that we do have
a commission uh to study uh alternative
road toll
fees and I I think we need to invite the
department I think that's probably the
right vehicle to get that conversation
going with was with valone's question
representative valone's question on how
much money is it really um it it seems
like the federal government we keep
hearing it's coming it's coming it's
coming it's not coming uh we're in
election cycle and so forth and next
year's Finance so it would be the the
best time to be doing this but I I would
like to invite you know um Department of
Transportation into a stronger
conversation on what's needed for for
Paving and bridges and so forth because
we need to be brave about it we need to
take it uh repres boy talks about you
know in the larger cities well we need
this much money we've got to do it you
take care of it uh it's something we we
can't kick it down the road Road
anymore um would you would you believe
any of that and would you think I I just
lost the commissioner but do you think
that we can we can get that going and
then work with work with our Senators
that are on that same committee is that
is that what we need to
do we think that that is what we need to
do we we think the number is about the
20 million do per per year the the
position the department takes is where
those funds come from we we leave to all
of you and Mr chairman you your success
story from supporting s SP 367 is on
page nine of this presentation and we
can give you more if if you need that
this this really shows the
accomplishment of the the sustained
investment so um as as a Department of
Transportation person
um I believe that the the the right way
to to fund transportation is through the
highway fund and and through the the
road toll and and I encourage your
discussions that's that's me what the
position we like to to take here with
the the the legislature is it's really
your decision you you may say well
really the general funds has funds right
now this is the place to do this so you
may be aware of a of another funding
source that's where I think we want to
be cautious and um work with you to to
accept your your ideas um I I do want to
say we have just a little bit of of time
on this s SP 367 is is going away um
this won't change in the in the snap of
a finger but it will begin to to change
quickly as we PVE less than that um 500
miles per
year thank you um further questions
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question um when you speak about the
higher costs in the last few years for
Paving would the cost of asphalt be one
of the higher ones yes the the cost of
asphalt is definitely a driver the cost
of Labor is a driver the cost of
equipment is a driver when we hear here
from from the the contractors they they
are very clear that they suffer all the
same supply chain issues every other
business does all the increased cost for
equipment but asphalt is definitely
among those and we have a chart in
another presentation that's geared
towards Paving that shows that increase
in and asphalt cement costs and of
course as that increases we pay fewer
miles follow up yes repres please being
that that being the case would you agree
that if the United States was increased
oil production as we can here and in the
free market that would lower the price
of
oil um would you say that would be a
benefit to the paving end of this thing
I would say I have an opinion but that's
beyond my expertise
assistant commissioner for Department of
Transportation thank you thank you for
the question represent uh representative
Jack then I'll come back to board uh
thank you um there's a huge amount of
federal funds in the Ia and a couple of
other Federal programs that have made a
huge difference in the Red lless Bridge
situation also over the last few years
and we uh that's it's totally due to
that funding source that we've been able
to do that
I would agree I would agree with with
that and that we we we I would also
agree that we have more Federal money
coming into Transportation now than we
we ever have but we also have a 10-year
plan with a lot of capital projects and
reconstruction projects that are
absorbing those those federal funds um
and this so we still wind up with they
loss as we lose sp3 67 there are also
limitations on those federal funds and
what roads they can be spent on and our
tier four roads is very limited um if
any federal funds that can be applied to
those roads so a modest State investment
is what helps us to take care of those
thank you represent
Boyd thank you Mr chairman thank you
again for taking my
question if there are
and I appreciate Mr oldenberg comments
regarding zero
being unrealistic because I would say
it's it's a circle it's like a circle it
keeps going it's never you're never
going to hit zero and I and I understand
and I appreciate that but with with that
being said the thing that has struck me
is your statement that you don't take a
position to ask for more for more money
but yet both of you have engineering
degrees that put you in an imminent
position of being qualified to talk
about whether a road is in good shape or
in crummy shape so with that being said
why has there historically been a
reticence by the dot to communicate the
road stink and that we need x amount of
dollars to get them up to
fair if I if I could let me just step in
for just a moment and if my questions if
I'm being held in contempt I apologize
Mr no no know I uh and I'm trying to
decide whether to put you on shoulders
and run you around the room they um I
weigh 185 they um I I think the
department I think you're going to hear
the same is we're the policy we're the
people that should and I I think there's
a concern of certain Personnel stepping
over their bounds on what they should do
with that said please yes and and what I
can what I can say is this committee
in the legislature solved that problem
largely for us in in 2014 with s SP
367 so again page nine of this
presentation from our perspective is a
success story we argue a lot internally
about whether we should rebuild every
one of these poor roads from the bottom
up spending a million to a million and a
half per mile or spend the 50 to 75,000
per mile to put a to put a thin lift of
of payment on them that's going to get
us seven or eight years what prior to
2014 our strategy really had been to try
to rebuild from the bottom up a lot of
our poor roads to get us out of the the
very poor condition what what I've
learned as as an engineer through
experience over over these past years is
that thin lift of pavement every 8 to 10
years on these very poor roads really is
the lowest life cycle cost to maintain
these roads and uh not perfect but I
think acceptable acceptable conditions I
think if we try to maintain all of our
Assets in good condition all the time
there's not enough money in the world
world just like um Bill had stated
earlier when when you think of the the
roof on your house right when's the most
economical time to change that roof the
day before it starts leaking and cost
you more if you change it two years
earlier five years earlier you've you've
taken the economics of that roof and
draw draw pushed up the annual cost of
it so well and perfect and while we
still have some poor and very poor roads
um I do think we're getting to a very
good cycle the other thing we're doing
internally as we pave these roads with
our forces we're going out and changing
pipes ahead of time we're doing ditching
uh ahead of time trying to get rid of
that water that is really the the
culprit of all the damage in a most cost
uh effective way so I do think we're
making progress and I do think if we
keep with this um strategy we are going
to drive the the best life cycle of the
roads I also think as these tier four
roads get a few more of those thinner
coats an inch or or a little bit less
they're going to to um perform a little
bit better in the long run as well not
perfectly but a little bit better rent
fauler
please so I think I remember when I was
a kid
we would drive along we would close our
eyes when we were approaching the state
line with Massachusetts and we'd try to
take guesses as to when we cross the
state line and you could hear it in the
tires because the roads in Massachusetts
were so much poorer than were're in New
Hampshire I think it was a matter of
Pride that we had good
roads and um and I think people still
would appreciate it but the the whole
issue of people's willingness to pay
seems to have
uh shifted
and you know it's a balance I understand
it's a balance and you mentioned $20
million as a figure was that just for
repaving is you bring it up yes because
I sort of doing my own calculations I
mean that's the only one place where
we're have shortcomings like the fact
that we're getting Federal money and not
putting up our own dollars to be able to
do more with the federal
dollars every other program assistance
to towns really hasn't gone up either
when they their costs are going up um is
there a number which would kind of get
us back
to a balance where
people would have the
same maybe I'm putting on the spot the
thing you didn't want to ask for but you
know I was estimating the shortfall of
being more like $60 million a year and
I'm wondering if you tried to come up
with a number that's like
that yeah to answer that question that
the $20 million is just to replace the
sp sp
367 and continue with our Paving
strategy it doesn't include any of the
other wants that that that people may
have or if we were to put together and
an overall strategy to improve condition
um what that dollar value would be would
be to continue the the maintenance
Paving that and the preservation Paving
that we've been doing at the rates that
we
have thank you please represent thank
you Mr chairman U when you you mentioned
a couple of times rebuilding sections or
or possibly rebuilding some tier four
maybe tier three roads does that include
digging down into the
substrate and um going from the you know
the very the gravel the the uh Crush Etc
and then all the way up to what
2 in or 4 Ines of pavement and how does
that compare to maybe if you know how
they do it in say in Europe say in
Germany do they go down deeper when they
are there different um depths to the
substrate when you're talking about
preparing a road bed that would be more
advantageous to us to uh get more
longevity out of that particular
road yeah so we we do have a we do have
different crosssections we call them
cross sections layers of of sand gravel
Crush gravel pavement base and and then
pavement that that we try to uh achieve
when we're talking you know a million to
a million and a half per mile on these
tier four roads that's a combination of
strategies and that's not building a a
Cadillac road going down five or six
feet that's going down 3 feet and
improving the the drainage and and so
forth so there are a number of designs
there's also some lower cost strategies
that we try to use instead of going down
deeper we try to use some of our
recycled materials either by um either
by reclaiming the pavement mixing the
existing pavement with the top select
materials or adding some Stone in and
reclaiming the the pavement or putting
some what we call cold plane millings uh
you see on the interstates when we grind
the pavement and haul that material away
that material sometimes goes into the
new asphalt we also Salvage a portion of
that to the dot and we'll put that down
on a poor Road at a lower cost per mile
to help improve it before we overlay it
with another pavement so there's a
number number of different strategies we
use at different costs to make
improvements if I could so
you're you hit on totally rebuilding the
road taking it down to to subbase just a
a sort
of history of roads in New Hampshire
most of the roads we're talking about
are unbuilt roads um we a lot of our
roads that still exist today um Route 28
through Alton was uh
was built in the 20s and the 30s it was
part of the was it the New Deal
depression yeah it was The Depression
get to work and and and spend money to
to bring the economy back that was six
inches of gravel and they they paved two
inches right it was it was to get the
Model T on a road there's no drainage
there was no nothing that road still
exists today so the problem is all we've
been able to do is pay
over you know LOM we that's because
that's what's under the road to to be
able to reconstruct those those roads
and a lot of the tier three and four
roads are like that they're the they're
the the the carriage paths you know that
people used to run their cattle down to
get them to you know to the center of
town you know they've over time paved
those there's there's no substructure
there's no drainage and that that's our
problem to be able to build rebuild
build these things is is $2 million a
mile and um so that I I understand where
you're going the cost of rebuilding a
road is is huge um and there's just too
many miles to be able to do that so um
that that's where we get into this is
the best most coste effective way of
keeping those roads in good
shape further questions at this
point do you want to continue on
and um looks like we'll probably we'll
probably go to lunch with this okay um
and after lunch if we still have
continued questions we can certainly
handle that in committee otherwise we'll
start moving into uh some of their recom
recommendations for amendments and so
forth so so I I think we were on page 10
to sort of go with represent Jack I
don't know if he was pushing us along or
not but red listed Bridges um so I'm the
question came up about the Le red listed
bridge status either both the state and
and and
municipalities uh the top uh graph and
and narrative go with the state red
listed Bridges So currently we have
about uh 200 or I'm sorry 119 red listed
Bridges um we we are putting an
additional $156 million over the 10
years so about 16 million more um
towards red listed
Bridges um what we're seeing in so we
run prediction models of what and this
is this is where it gets a little tough
is you never know when a bridge is going
to Ender the red list but we we try to
put predictions to it um and determine
when we think it's going to degrade
enough certain components enough to get
on the red list so we we Rite the deck
the substructure which is the steel that
holds it up and then the sub the the the
sub I'm sorry the deck the super
structure which is the steel that holds
it up and then the substructure with the
foundation when those get to a certain
point really bad it's a 0 to 10 rating
four or less puts it on the red list for
any of those three um what we are
looking at is we we determine how long a
bridge stays above the red list and over
time it degrades and when it gets on the
red list so
what we predict is that over the 10-year
plan as a bridge comes on we'll we will
be able to take a bridge
off um so that's why you see a sort of a
straight line in reality it's going to
go a little you know look like an EKG a
little bit but the the idea is over the
10-year plan um the the number should
stay steady as a bridge goes off the
10-year plan another one will be added
um so we we're predicting about 118 at
the the end of the 10-year plan so about
the same number as we have today so we
have enough funding you know to keep our
heads above water um we actually have
more funding to be able to do Bridges uh
than we do roads um so that it's a good
thing so we we we can keep the the state
uh Bridges um maintained and and in good
shape um from a municipal red list so we
there were 214 bridges on the municipal
Red List uh 43 of those were in a DOT
funded um program to to be either
repaired or
replaced um and at the last presentation
we talked about the additional Federal
money um that could be used on Municipal
owned Bridges this is sort of a first of
its kind be able to use federal money on
a community-owned
bridge so we were able to fund 56 more
Bridges Community you know Municipal
Bridges um you know using Federal money
um through the program so we we have
almost a hundred uh Bridges Municipal
bridges that will be either re rehabed
or replaced in the program so we predict
that um that number will go down on the
municipal side the problem is we don't
have the same prediction models with the
municipal Bridges uh while we do inspect
the municipal Bridges a a lot of
communities don't have a budget to
repair um maintain preserve Bridges it's
we wait until it gets on the red list
and we do something about it so it's
it's it's a hard judge of um you know
how you know how long a bridge uh will
on a municipal side will last before it
becomes red listed so um right now we
think the municipal side is is in better
shape um I will say on the state side
not only do we have federal funds to uh
to get Bridges off the red list our
Bridge maintainers um
which use use State money uh go out and
remove bridges you know a dozen or so
Bridges from the Red List each year
through maintenance activities um that
they have the capability of we have the
capability of doing
ourselves um
so any questions on red list if
um maybe uh maybe you've already
provided could you provide the committee
uh with a list of those bridges that are
on that list you don't have to you know
it's broken up by town but could you
just send us that
list we we have that list I thought we
may have supplied it the last meeting
but I I'm I'm not sure we will a PDF
would be fine if you could send it I've
been in and out of here so I apologize
go ahead um so on page 11 we talk the
question came out about public
involvement how we involve um uh the
public in our decision making and and
and Alternatives uh especially with our
roadway projects so on page 11 we we
this is sort of the the steps involved
in a highway project we go from data
collection through alternative analysis
um you know pref you know selecting that
preferred alternative uh if we need
formal public hearing we we do that
um finalizing the environmental
documents associated with that uh
preferred alternative so we can get
permitting uh developing the
construction plans once we have that
alternative we can go into final design
and and develop those plans and then
that then finally constructing um the
the project so those are the steps in
the project on page 12 we sort of
outline uh how we we we involve the
public in this decision
making um I I will say as a as an
overall view on a standard project The
public's involved the whole way through
uh but public involvement is project uh
dependent uh a Paving project we talk
about Paving a lot we don't have a lot
of public involvement in Paving right
there's not a lot of impact um we let
the communities know that we're going to
pave their road we don't have public
meetings typically we put out a public
notice um there's not a lot of public
involvement that goes into a project
like that on a typical project though we
do um have public involvement you could
picture this is a a a bridge uh you know
Bridge Project where we're going to
either rehab or replace a bridge or a
roadway project you know typically on a
a project like that uh the the public
involvement is tailored uh to the
project a lot of times after we collect
the data after we go out and do survey
data collection you know count cars uh
you know deir some of the base
environmental information we have what
we call a blank sheet meeting we'll go
out to the public officials and say we
have this project we're going to replace
this bridge or fix this road what can
you tell us that is important to you
what do you think um uh you know the
community is looking for uh for an
answer or solution what do you deem as
important to this you know make this
project successful it's our way of you
know one is portraying that there's a
project coming we want their input we we
take their input so that we're not just
starting you know gung-ho without any
information we want the community's
input in in what the project should
entail we see that a lot with roads we
talk about sidewalks and shoulders you
know turning Lanes uh you know things
like that for a bridge it might be you
know if it's a historic Bridge you know
is the look need to stay the same or can
we close the bridge is there a thought
about closing the bridge so we can do
this faster um are there D2 routs you
know emergency access things like that
those are the things we want to know
upfront before we start going in the
wrong direction a lot of
projects that
are you know immensely important to the
community we have stakeholder groups or
public advisory committees so these p s
or state holder groups these are groups
of you know 15 20 Community folks that
lead the discussion uh in the direction
that we take so they offer immense input
these are you know select board members
you know City counselors uh you know all
the way down to you know citizens at
large that are involved um in in what
the the scope of this project would look
like when we do the alternative studies
on a project we will have a public
officials meeting this is these are the
Alternatives that we've you know we've
developed um you know your thoughts as
the you know the governing body of the
Town um we also would then follow up
with a public informational meeting
where we invite the public and the
abutters to a a meeting to talk about
and get their input on on what
alternatives they like or want to see
you know the pluses and minuses
sometimes depending on the size of the
project we combine those meetings into
one ultimately we use that input um in
developing a preferred alternative once
we we have that preferred alternative we
then would typically go back have
another public informational meeting
saying this is the project now this is
what it's going to look like these are
the details and uh gather input again uh
if needed that we had to acquire
property we would have a formal public
hearing for us that's uh you know public
hearing is is gives us the right of
domain you know we don't like using
eminent domain we do on occasion have to
uh but the public hearing gives us that
right and that lays out in great detail
the property the details of the or the
project the the details of the project
and that input um what what I will say
is and I I know where this this this
came from this these questions is we try
to involve the public
um in depth throughout the process
sometimes it doesn't work sometimes we
can't reach consensus on the on the
preferred
alternative um so we see two things is
you know two issues that we have time
and not being able to reach
consensus the time issue is public
officials and public opinion changes we
start a project One Way public officials
change say I don't like that we seene
where people run for office in their
town to oppose one of our projects
that's not uncommon so um you know and
that so that time tends to be a killer
when when we see that and the other is
um where we can't reach
consensus on a on a on a project um we
we can't make everybody happy and the
sort of a fact of life um but it's it's
where
we where where where folks can't say
yeah that I recognize this is the best
solution I don't really like it but I
accept it and um you know we've seen a
couple of those um you know last year
the Conway project Do's proposal Town
supported it majority of the public
supported it but there were property
owners that didn't support it so they
tried to change the solution through
legislation and and we know the outcome
and just a few weeks ago here was was
the town of Salem was here trying to
change um actually a design of of their
own project um and trying to legislate
change that way so um I know the example
that came up was wolfboro project um
that project has a 20year history with
us 20 years ago we were out and they
didn't like the solution so we went home
they've brought this project to us
through the 10-year plan um they had an
idea of the solution they had a plan a
master plan we've tried to incorporate
those components we have a majority of
of of acceptance and consensus on what
the road is it's a couple of the
intersections um the idea was thrown out
a roundabout versus different things um
the in the long run the roundabout one
that wasn't by consensus that was sort
of a majority rule type of type of
approach and you know I think now we
seen the the folks that don't like the
roundabouts are are are coming out and I
think that's some of the the feedback
that we got so we try our hiest artist
to involve the public um so we don't end
up in this situation but that's that the
reality is is we can't make everybody
happy um even though we try so that's I
just I just want to say that group pboro
again rang my bell so there there
apparently is a different phone number
that's being called now but I I I I had
missed I had missed the conversation
other day and just that synopsis of what
you just said was extremely helpful to
me thank you I'm not to belabor the
wolfboro issue but we had a public
involvement plan that involved a a pack
20 people from the community were
involved in the decision making that
that group met
over five times over the last three
years to make decisions on what the
project is we had two public
informational meetings we've had surveys
uh multimedia surveys where people could
offer their
input I don't know I don't know how much
more we involve the public in some of
this decision making especially in
Project like that so
um on page 13 and 14 question came up
about uh Boston Express the ridership um
and and the subsidy involved in in the
Boston Express so um on page 13 is a
slide of um the ridership from
2017 uh to
2023 you'll see the the ridership uh
before covid uh was fairly high it's
dropped off over Co and slowly picking
up but we see that it is picking up um
in in ridership and the subsequent slide
on
14 and it it sort of goes hand hand in
hand um the less ridership the more of
the subsidy that you see um so you see
that subsidy had gone up as ridership
went down uh during the covid years but
it's slowly the subsidy is going down as
ridership picks up we envision that the
ridership will continue uh to to pick up
hopefully getting back to prepandemic
levels uh sooner than
later I don't know if there's any more
questions about the Boston Express
all right um the next was the questions
about the capital Corridor project uh
question was really how much money did
we spent how much is left and and what
would it take to to continue that
project to completion getting the new
starts Grant application in uh so on the
on the project itself it was uh $5.4
million of FTA funds um to uh do the the
do that project um the core components
were were completed but it didn't
totally complete that project before it
was halted uh we spent $4.6 million on
that project the remaining so the uh
question was how much money is remaining
it was about 861 million or I'm sorry
$861,000 of grant funding left um that
money was
distributed uh to NASA city of NASA for
their transit system and Manchester
Transit Authority for FDA eligible
activity so that
$861,000 was distributed uh through
other FDA means so there is no money
remaining in that Grant um the
additional work to take that project to
completion and get a new start Grant
application would be approximately that
$861,000 that was the goal of that
project uh
originally I would say with inflation
you're probably talking more in the
million dollar range and and that uh to
pick that up and finish it so that was
um hopefully answers the capital
Corridor questions thank you um on page
16 we received some questions about the
the the the gas tax the road chol uh and
where it went so we wanted to provide
this information gives you an idea of um
the the 22.2 Cent gas tax where where
that funding is distributed um as I
think the commissioner uh testified last
time about 60% comes to the dot 40% goes
to others like the department of safety
that's listed here
um the it so the the cents
are we have exact to the tenth of a
scent where this money goes and that's
not really the case this is sort of a
snapshot some of those f I'll use block
Grand Aid is distributed by percentage
of Revenue um
so s SP
367 uh is a component of this so Number
Four The Debt Service and State Bridge
Aid 3.7 cents that is directly
s367 but 12% of s SP 367 also goes to
block Grand Aid which is number two so
whereas I'd love to say 0.5 cents goes
to Black Grand Aid that necess
necessarily isn't the case each year
it's it could fluctuate because it's a
percentage but this sort of gives you a
breakdown of the road toll where where
it goes um because I think the confusing
part was in our Slide the 10-year plan
three cents is betterment and 4.2 cents
is sp 367 and that's the state funds
that come out of there that's directly
goes into the 10-year
plan questions yes represent boy I know
I'm in my second term but this is kind
of a newbie question I apologize what
percentage of the operating cost to the
Department of Safety what is that
fund I don't know the operating cost for
the Department of Safety correct and how
that breaks down the
12.9% I don't
know is is the question uh on the
40% that didn't full question oh the
percent of the operating cost that goes
to the Department of Safety so the 12.9
cents and what and what is it used
for what is it used for Department of
Safety uh generally uh uh Troopers okay
Y and I think uh it's uh the cost of
collections th throws it in there but uh
I'm I'm working off memory we do have a
detailed chart that that that breaks it
down and and pass for years but um
um roughly it's 60% that of of that 12.9
of the unrestricted Revenue goes to
Department transportation operating cost
um it's a little more than 30% I think
that goes to Department of Safety and
then other agencies um divy up the rest
some some go to the courts some go to uh
some other agencies that have roadway
enforcement actions if if if I could
take you commissioner back to your lowly
days of being a bridge engineer I
believe when you started in here um
there was there was a strong debate on
how much money the department of safety
many years ago was was taking from the
highway fund u u paying for fleets of uh
new cars and everything else and um do
was Lo was not getting enough revenue or
we felt as a policy that they weren't
and so we passed legislation that
limited that am I is that am I on the
right track there commissioner yes yeah
there was the there was some um there
there was some restrictions I think the
Restriction was roughly around um
roughly around 30% was was where it was
maxed for Department of Safety but um I
I I I know in the past the the
legislature has also waved their own
rules to make um budgets um balance
so thank you further questions yes
please repres simp thank you Mr chairman
i' like to can we just briefly go back
to slide uh 15 just real quick uh the
remaining funds $861,000 for the um
Capital CA
project I thought we already moved
beyond that one just real quick thank
you um what what didn't get done in the
study um I I can speak to that um I I I
know what what didn't get done in the
study was um and and I think I had
answered this at the at the at the
public hearing the last work session um
we completed the financial document we
completed the draft environmental impact
statement um there was um continued
coordination with MBTA development of um
inter inter agency operating agreements
as well as uh completion of a final
environmental impact statement and uh
development of a um FTA new starts uh
Grant application so those were some of
the major elements that um um that were
originally scoped out but um didn't
didn't didn't uh follow through to
completion thank you you're welcome
thank you represent bone you had
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so on the i93
debt service at State Bridge a it's 3.7
cents of that three .7 cents how much is
uh devoted to The Debt Service and also
when does that debt service
end there is a chart from the previous
one
um essential essentially all of that
goes to The i93 Debt Service
um yeah the other the other parts in the
waterfall um uh that that goes to um uh
block grant Aid or state aid Bridge are
already um are already taken out so that
3.7 cents would go to The i93 Debt
Service the full Debt Service kicks in
uh in
2025 and uh it it's projected to extend
to
2034 rep Jack yeah if you look at page
21 of the handout from last time right
yeah thank you uh that's where it is The
Debt Service is in the third column
oh yeah and then the what's spent on the
uh Road improvements is in the second to
last
column further uh questions for the
department and um if I could open up um
a new discussion May and I apologize I
haven't had the time I wished I could
have in committee this year
turnpikes the um some of the discussion
if I remember
right um there's always been a
discussion of how we can or an inability
to expand a
Turnpike and that we weren't allowed by
typically to um if we were to expand at
Turnpike then to be able to toll that
new section of
Turnpike my understanding from some of
the meetings I've been attending over
the over the year that there are there
are states that are actually being
permitted to expand their term
bikes and they are also then able to
toll those new sections of
Road um it is has the department heard
any to that I um is my question and I'd
be happy to provide that information or
would it would it possibly be of benefit
to our state if we were to do
that I think off off off the off off the
cuff Mr chairman uh I I I think it's a
choice or or or or a balance
um uh I I know in in the in the past we
have expanded the turnpike system uh it
it came with a cost um I think it was
around 10 years or so ago where where
the highway fund or where the turnpike
actually bought a section of of the
turnpike uh let me let me get this
straight the turnpike bought a section
of I95 from from the highway fund the
section that went from the um uh ports
MC traffic circle up to the uh piscatqua
River Bridge uh that had been a a
highway funded piece of of
I95 um it was somewhere in excess of
$130 million that the turnpike system
had had had had bought that from the
highway fund and that is now a Turnpike
asset we had looked at other proposals
in the past as part of the bo conquered
um uh project to look at extending the
turnpike system right now the turnpike
ends at Exit 14
right right here down here at the bottom
of the hill in conquered we had looked
at considering expanding the turnpike
system up to uh the maram river so that
393 and that full length of Bo conquered
could be um Incorporated within within
the turnpike and with that proposal
would have come a uh you know a
systemwide toll increase to to fund that
uh acquisition uh so
um I think some of those tweaks and
stuff to to to answer the first party
question those things can be considered
and and looked at we have had some
experience with expanding the turnpike
system but it does come at a cost and a
willingness to uh you know consider
increasing um uh toll rates to support
it
the I believe when we passed our last
10year budget or our 10-year plan
um the Continental Boulevard it was a
recommendation of this of the 10year
plan to remove that and I believe it it
it then
later um was pulled from our
recommendation do do you have any
updates uh that you could share on on
what that is costing your department to
continue the maintenance of that I don't
need them now but um in the next day or
so I would appreciate that yep I can't
remember off the top of my head but you
you were right that was a that was a
recommendation I think in the Senate
phase of the 10year plan that that um
that change had had come out um and we
are continuing to maintain Continental
Boulevard um and I don't know if it'll
come to house public works but there is
there is there are some bills relative
to um um uh salt use and and winter
maintenance along uh some of that
section that that house Public Works may
be seeing coming over from the Senate so
I'd assume it's not costing us any less
to continue to maintain that section of
Road that's correct and that would
that's Revenue that you don't have to
keep your Turnpike system as as viable
correct okay thank you the um questions
on that before I move
on yes please thank you Mr chairman just
for clarity so you talk about the
turnpike system coming up to Exit 14 is
that the Fe Turnpike yes is it this the
signage on the um at least as you go
north doesn't quite depict that I think
it says
293 just circum Manchester so it so it
goes all the way up to here up to up to
Exit 14 yes yeah it's probably kind of a
Nuance most people driving it driving
through the tolls through through hooks
it you're on i93 but um everything thing
from Exit 14 um South um through the
hooks of tolls that's one of the reasons
we can we can toll I 93 there is because
it is part of the turnpike system so
yeah the fever Turnpike actually
predates the interstate system um it
originally ran from the mass line in in
nashwa up to up to the um up to what was
a a traffic circle at the end of the F
fep Turn Pike here
conquered thank you you're
welcome I I have another and this this
would be our time if there's extraneous
questions uh for the Department because
we're going to afternoon uh we're going
to start moving into amendments and so
forth um I I had the opportunity to
attend a u I think it was executive
counselor's snowmobile ride a few days
ago and while I wasn't able to uh to
ride U I had conversations with u the
different department Department of
Safety and and rails and everyone else
was there and um we have a bill that we
passed through committee which was
talking about the Conway
Branch um which is Corridor 19 for the
rail system starting incenter oopy and
going into a multimodal trail as a
opposed to uh the
rails and and I heard something that was
stressful to me from uh from that
conversation and I followed up with uh
commissioner Stewart and i' I'd like to
I'd like to hear the commissioner's
point of you because the the rail
division is under your
department Trails division which is
snowmobiles and and other items are
under um under
um commissioner Stewart's
department and we were talking about um
we're sitting there and they were not
able to take the ride where they wanted
to because the to to ride would have
sent them across a section of rail in uh
Tamworth and oy that has a lot of
switches and other rails and with the
lack of snow and melting it becomes
unsafe to pass through
that and whether and I don't know who
owns Which but
the in spots like that the rail Divi the
trail Division I apologize I'll throw
those wrong the trails division
sometimes has a RightWay which will get
them off of the track so they can make
some of those
connections when we were hearing
testimony in here uh um on possibly um
removing
rails and uh loose ties up above and
creating a flat surface in that section
10 Mile section from OS to Silver Lake
um the
um the uh the provider uh North Coast
rail North Coast railroad had mentioned
uh they have um they're in the process
of pulling rails and ties for their
section and they were sharing some
numbers of what that cost would be to
bring the rails that are un that are not
functional now to an operational level
and it's it's worse than our number that
we're talking about a million dollars a
mile U to re to recreate
that yeah they but what what I heard was
that in some sections up north where the
where the um trail trail would normally
pull those rails and then would have the
ability to share in the revenue of the
scrapping of that
material because their department is
stressed every bit as much as your
department is I understand there's a new
policy
now uh from from the Department of
Transportation that they no longer um do
Rail and Transit no longer allows us to
salvage the steel when pulling rails as
they like to keep them inhouse for
future
use old rails old rails that from my
understanding in your Department's much
more in tune to if we're digging a
septic I can tell you what I think you
know you know better than me on Rails
but we've been told that that 70b rail
is or whatever it might be is way
insufficient for any new use coming
forward so I would I would appreciate it
if if you could comment now or if you
could get back to me uh because if I
remember right the state of New
Hampshire whether it was your department
we we we paid a fee to to take that
Corridor in to preserve it and then in
the event that rail or Freight or
passenger was to come back we have to
turn turn that back over to whoever now
owns the
railroad so I guess my question is if we
have been salvaging some of that or
maybe we haven't been but it sounded
like the department had been salvaging
that has something
changed because it would it would by
eliminating by causing the department
Trails not to be able to remove some of
that rail is a safety issue and up north
it maybe not so much here and
and speaker Chandler would chastise me
for saying up north because my area is
not the North country that's uh but
between my area and the Lakes Region and
the North
Country snowmobile is is a tremendous
revenue for us and I was excited to hear
that hoping at some point with that we
can be able to connect to fryberg and
then our connection just goes everywhere
so I'm wondering is that a policy by
your department
now um Shelly knows I'm going to call
her there sorry I did I did
not um with this if you want to let her
sit down sorry um I'll put her on on the
spot a little bit but I I would say it's
I don't think it's a new policy I think
we have always look to salvage the the
rail that we can and um I think it's you
know we we and it's and it's salvaged
primarily for maintenance and use on on
the other active areas of of uh Trail
usage of uh rail usage so um I I
understand what you're saying with North
Coast saying that uh you know they were
going to put any um any any um upgraded
a new service or or or anything on that
that uh the cost to upgrade rail and
upgrade those lines is is is quite
expensive but um the salvage value that
that that we look for the for those
rails is to you know go back into the um
existing areas of active rail line um to
help def Fray those maintenance costs uh
primarily and I I think it's been a
common practice I don't think it's a new
policy but Shelley I'll let you explain
if I could go there I ju I just want to
clear up it was this has this has
nothing to do with the railroad on what
they're doing in in in you know they
they have a section of line that ends in
Osby that's that's that's theirs and
they're doing those repairs this this
conversation has nothing to do with the
benefit of any rail company sure my
question is
and is
where we we have
um for what purpose is that rail going
to be repurposed and have and have we
allowed sections to be removed for the
the trail division because I would hope
they're good stewards with you
so yeah for the record my name is
Shelley Winters I'm the director of
Aeronautics Rail and Transit I apologize
if I mumble a little bit today um yeah
it's been a policy and a practice for
probably about 10 plus years that I was
in the bureau before I moved to the
commissioner's office that any uh
railroad lines that were being converted
for trails if the rail and the other
track material the switches and the
plates being pulled out had any
salvageable reuse on the active lines we
require whether the dot manages the
project or dncr manages the project that
they Salvage those materials and we
store them to use on an active line if
they're in poor shape if they're too
worn out or if it's a lower rail weight
than we try to use then we allow dncr or
the town whoever that trail sponsor is
to salvage those materials and put it
towards the cost of their project so
it's really specific project by project
area by area that we make those
determinations on whether we Salvage to
reuse to the state or whether we allow
the project sponsor to recoup that
salvage value we do not take the
components just to get salvage value if
it's salvage value selling it to a
scrapper dot will not be involved it's
only if it saves the state money so we
don't have to buy any other rail on an
active section
so so if I could do you have and I don't
expect you can tell me to the foot or
even to the mile of rail for the for the
rail that is of this Sub in this in this
Corridor that we're speaking about
19 and and some of the others has has
any of that product been
reused for for projects within the same
Corridor when and when we say we're
storing I assuming we're not picking
that rail up and transporting it
anywhere else you are we are so if we do
Trail projects we'll try to bring if we
are going to salvage it for use on a
state owned line we try to bring it to
the closest Stockyard um or railroad
oper tenant that we have to put it for
future use this line that we're talking
about the the stone Conway branch is
approximately 21 miles long um with the
exception of roadways where the rail has
been taken out and the road has been
temporarily paved over we have not
removed any rail from those sections to
salvage anywhere else we'd have to go
and inspect and look at the weight of
the rail which may be lighter than we
use in a lot of places and the condition
of that rail to see whether or not it
has a reuse value to the state but we
have not completed that assessment at
this point would it would it be possible
and and thank you for your time I'm I'm
hoping there's a day you and I are going
to lunch and I'm not just asking you
questions
that day is coming soon the
um Can is it possible to get an
inventory of of what that looks like
that that amount of rail that you have
stored historically is that is that
possible someone know what that
accounting is from that Corridor or
Statewide oh we'll start with that
Corridor but Statewide would be nice to
know it it I don't need it for this week
but if if I'd like I'd like to see what
that I would like to see what that is
there was another comment here by the um
by commissioner
Stewart
um Salvage steel now pass this along as
they keep in house for future use also
another new requirement is that we must
complete formal surveys of the Rails
prior to removal as they as they
consider the rails a survey Monument to
determine the correct property
boundaries I'm I'm somewhat confused by
that statement because we have requested
in oy we have
requested
um layouts of of the uh of the rail road
which showed where culverts were and
everything else and it it would appear
to me as a Layman who looks at plans
that line rail there there are defined
points monuments and so forth for and
that that I don't I don't know that that
statement's entirely I'd love to be
schooled on that am I
wrong I don't work for the Bureau of
RightWay but in talking with our
surveyors and appraisers the railroad
Val Maps some of which you may be
referring to um chair that show culverts
those were developed in the 1800s
they're very Antiquated we don't have
newer layers uh in GIS at this point so
the monumentation is usually to know
what State owns is off the center line
of the rail line so if you don't survey
and have those meets and Bounds of where
the current rail is before you pull it
out to become a trail it becomes an
issue when you work with the butters if
you say you own 30 or 45 feet off the
center line of track and the track is
not there and you have a trail that was
built and you don't have the confidence
that the trail was built directly on the
center line of track then you get into
an issue with every linear a butter
along miles and miles so um it is
something that we did not require in the
past that we have had problems dealing
with encroachers property U management
issues that uh Bureau of RightWay who
are experts in this field had said this
is really the only way to take all the
existing lines and use the existing Rail
lines and use that Center of rail to now
reestablish and be able to match up with
those uh original railroad valuation
maps from the
1800s and I and I appreciate that that
conversation um but the if if it's a
center line and we have we have an
existing rail that's running running
down running down making turns climbing
2% and so forth I would assume that the
only survey data that you were looking
for to be done to any standards is just
simply projecting what that Center Line
is down through there which which is a
much
easier um
item to accomplish a um after the fact
and as built um is is that indeed all
that that all that the department is is
asking for at this point in time are
they looking to map not only the lines
the center line The Edge and everything
else because that that's an expensive
process yeah I would have to double
check and we can follow back up I know
trying to establish just we the center
line and then everything else we can
measure off I believe but we'll formally
follow up as with some of the other
information requested I I sincerely
appreciate your
time if uh if policy if the legislature
was determined that a
policy change might be legislatively
possible then that would be
the the preview of the legislature I
would
assume a policy a a policy if if a
policy change on on on the um on the um
on the use of the old
rail sure yeah yeah it could be uh
legislated like I said our our our
practice has been you know primarily to
Def to defay or defer or yeah deey other
maintenance costs on the on the active
active Lines by um you know reusing what
is salvageable uh rail that's compatible
with the you know existing active lines
so okay thank you further questions for
the commissioner for the yes
please thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm a little
confused here because it seems like the
system you said that you use you use the
existing rails to find the center but
hasn't GPS kind of done away with all
that or have you gone through and
changed everything over the GPS or do
you still go out there and measure from
the
rails uh somebody would have to if we
have a piece of paper that that that
that shows the the valve plan that shows
the the the right of way um constraints
relative to the center line of of rail
whether it's whether it's fully surveyed
or GPS somebody would still have to go
out and physically do that and lay that
out from from the paper in in the field
so whether it's you know GPS or um or or
full
survey there still an activity that has
to
happen is am I answering your question I
I it it to a degree but it seems like
we're doing keeping the rails for that
purpose once it's GPS it doesn't seem
like it needs to be done I know when you
do some roads like I live near 125 and
when that was done recently enough the
measurements are so accurate that the
center of the road is actually the
center of the road so sometimes it would
seem like with the rails the center of
the rail may not be the center of the
rail unless it was done unless it was
updated so I guess my concern is that
you're going to keep those rails there
just so you know where the center is
when there's new ways to do it no I
don't think we're saying keeping it
there for that I think the the the
answer to uh the Chairman's question was
when when there is a project to tear up
the existing rails and and remove them
before they are removed uh because of
past experiences and past problems we
are requiring a a survey of that Center
Line so it's a established before the
before the rail line before the before
the rails and that monumentation of
where the center line of the rail is is
lost as part of a trail project thank
you for the correction yeah represent
fauler I just trying to add that
essentially that process is taking the
rail which is the only Monument they
have and replacing it with some other
Monument pins or or concrete bounds so
that they can measure property lines in
the future yes exactly it's once you've
established a new monument then you
don't need the rails anymore
right thank you but like like I think
your your point representative is there
is there is a there is a there is a cost
to a uh somebody you know dncr or Trail
sponsor developing that that project
there is an incremental cost to provide
that um um that monumentation that
survey as part of their their project so
I I fully I fully understand that but
when we're we're dealing with a state
agency
rails
Trails
do um it would seem when when you have a
collaborative project there I I would I
know we're you're all operating as we
are in the public service with 25% less
than what we would like to have
employees and and perhaps I'm completely
wrong because no one has told me this
but it would seem to me the Department
of Transportation for a small section of
what I understand to be switching at
intersections and things I I would hope
that we could we could hope that
do Trail and rail possibly could share
some surveying and so forth um it would
just it would just seem to be the right
thing and I and I would hope that it's
already being done but if it's not I I
offer maybe a com ation perfect
good all right any anything else could
we end this on a happy note let's pull
up something here yes please represent
uh maybe it's not appropriate this at
this time but are we going to be uh
maybe after lunch going through the
project amendments we C we certainly are
that was that was my intent was to try
and get through most of this now and and
we'll go there thank you yep further
questions why don't we uh why don't we
stop at this point and we will come back
at
1:00 all
right
e
e e
so I'd like to go ahead and open up our
afternoon session here um before we
start speaking of uh project
amendments uh were there time you had
for lunch were there any other questions
that were generated from this morning's
uh conversation which centered around uh
this
handout seeing none oh I'm sorry please
go ahead represent below thank you I
just have a question about red lists
and
and I'm sorry if I missed this but so
there's red list but what how do you dis
distinguish between bridges that just
get on the red list and those that are
in real need Ian like what's the
differentiation is there a score that
goes with that yes so we do a bridge
inspection every on a a regular bridge a
non- red listed Bridge every two years
on a red listed Bridge every year so
what we do is we inspect three
components the deck the super structure
which is the steel that holds a deck up
and then the substructure which is the
foundations and the peers and uh they're
given a rating of 0 to 10 really 10
being a brand new bridge and zero being
it's probably in the water um and
anything under a any any component that
rates a four or less is added to the
lead red list that means it needs needs
some work um to increase its capacity
increase its
structural um uh structural Integrity uh
to get it off the red list usually
you'll see a down posting once it's on
the Red List uh because it's uh either
rusted or there's some loss of
structural Integrity that that means it
can't support you know full Highway
loads
um when we inspect them every year
that's when we do that rating and it'll
will compare the rating or any change
versus the last inspection and then that
determinations made what that score is
um if it if it any component goes to
below a four a four or less um it gets
added to the Red List um if it's higher
than that we we use that as an indicator
um when a when a one of the components
is a five it's really close to be a
problem um it could stay a five for five
years 10 years 20 years we every bridge
is a little different uh before it it
makes the jump to a a red list so that
that
the red list is just sort of a litmus
test that we need to really pay better
attention to that bridge just followup
and the followup is just so your
priority is set by the lowest Bridges
with the lowest scores get the the
highest priority is that correct or is
that is there no there's a we have a a
bridge committee that
reviews um each Bridge
individually um so an example is a an
interstate Bridge has a higher priority
so it may rank higher be higher on the
replacement Bridge than a than a a
secondary or or a tier three or four
Bridge they may both be in the same
condition but because of the volume um
and everything else that the that the
bridge handles it might be higher on the
L last okay thank
you representative Jack uh thank you
didn't we some years ago enact a
definition of red list for this purpose
so that functionally obsolete was not
considered but structurally deficient
was so that we wouldn't get so that we
get the the structually deficient
bridges on the red L correct correct so
a a covered bridge still a bridge it'll
always be on the red list because it
can't hold loads so you know it was that
definition that allowed us to take some
of these bridges that are always going
to be red listed like that off of the
red list so that we weren't focusing our
attention on those type of bridges yes
thank you any further questions
okay we are going to uh move on to now
start speaking of the
draft uh amendments as necessary for the
10-year Plan before we do that I'd like
to represent I'd like to uh
representative Jack yeah there's been
some confusion about I mean House Bill
2024 says enact the book which is this
uh so the question is uh we're we're
some of us are confused about whether
the projects on this page that you just
handed out need to be amended into house
bill 2024 or if they're already in the
book so that's probably a Nuance that I
wasn't prepared for but if all these
projects are in the book some of them
are changes to dollar amounts some of
them are changes where we've removed a
project so um the idea would be is that
these are
changes to projects that are either are
are in the book well follow up then but
if you're changing the dollar amount
that changes what should be in the book
and it would be an
amendment so I believe we update the
book prior to it being signed so these
are recommendations that we'd like to
make to the book and with your okay or
approval we will make these changes and
they will appear in the book that is
signed in the
law okay so if if that's the case and
I'm I'm not
sure I I I I believe in the past and I'm
always open to be told I'm wrong is that
house bill like in this year
2024 would would show up as
amended with changes and you're you're
the impression you can get back to it
whether it comes through not as because
I guess my question would be if this
committee were to ask for an
amendment to be included in the 10-year
plan at what point does it become
amended it would seem or is the
Department's position that if we come up
with a committee Amendment it goes into
that book it's not amended so we and
like the
past legislation that that is in the
book okay would have the bill with the
with these project amendments
in in the wording of of House Bill 2024
and that would be part of in the front
of the book
so I'm not so yes I think the the
project amendments would appear
in House Bill 2024 as
amendments repr I
believe right so my question is if
somebody looks up House Bill 2024 as
introduced do they get this
book or is there some other language
that's in the
bill as introduced I I don't believe the
book is the item that comes forward
it's so somebody from the public can
they can they find this online if they
were looking for the Bill yes yes the
the book is on on one yeah so then okay
perhaps we could get we could get that
answer just so we know the the intent is
if if we can reach agreement that we get
whatever change is done and if there is
amendment so that we can possibly vote
for this as a committee this week on
Friday when we're scheduled and if it
can't happen this week then it'll be two
weeks out because we'll be I don't
intend on bringing the committee in next
week when we're not in session okay
we we will figure that out
okay rep s melson thank you Mr chairman
uh this is just going back last week and
I asked this question I just want to
make sure we're all on the same page
with this we got a little package with
project amendments on it and things like
that last week and as far as I can tell
these last week's project amendments are
already in this book
correct yes
I'm I'm looking at at til well there's
we have we have a differing opinion per
I'm look at tilon
42600 from the from right off the top
and it said remove roundabout from scope
and if I look at it the the roundabout
is been removed so that was that was the
list of gaset changes right and so the
the the gas changes are in the book
because that book was printed for the
governor then the governor's office
changes are in the
book then the do administrative update
which is
44493 on on ADD project back to the book
are not in the book that's not in the
book The do administrative updates Okay
repr g then J
Jack well uh thank you Mr chairman and
and thanks for answering the question or
my comment um basically you know there
at least one exception to what's not in
the book and that is the
causeway the causeway is on this list
it's not on the
book um which is quite an item for
people and then I'll we'll go over some
others after that's just want to mention
that right
now so response for that so it
was It was supposed to be in the book it
was all written up and ready to be in
the book it's just a button wasn't
pushed so it didn't print in the book so
it's it this this change will put it in
the book
um and it was as promised um you know
Construction in I
think 32 33 and um we Advanced the
design uh to to start in 26 okay so we
agreed to advance the design as part of
the gaset
process represent represent Jack well
I'm I'm still confused so now it sounds
like the Adit the last section are
things that are not in the book and
would need to be added by an amendment
by a committee
Amendment maybe does does Kathy M hamson
remember how this was done in the past
Maybe
techology not
so
if please if I may yes it's my
understanding that this amendment we are
asking you to pass is an administrative
Amendment these are changes that we are
aware of that need to be made to the
book since the the ex gasset had it and
since the governor had it it is true
that some of these projects on this list
are already in the plan and these are
dollar value changes that exceed a
million dollars that we're asking this
committee to approve so we can update
the book once again as it leaves house
trans house Public Works and goes to
Senate
Transportation so with your approval of
this amendment we will again update the
the
book so my question I I understand that
part so if this committee were to have a
Amendment or two amendments to be added
that would have to be incorporated into
the book when you're doing that so when
it comes to the floor it's still going
to be House Bill
2024 and does not have to be called as
amended because I I remember in the past
I thought it had been rep
boy has the legislative language to 2024
been written yet y
it's
draft okay follow up my my understanding
is that 2024 is a place saver until the
legislative language is actually drawn
up so the way that I'm
sorry but it says draft on it m says
draft okay I'm saying this because
follow Mr chairman yes I'm saying this
because if the legislative language
hasn't been drafted yet then what's
being proposed by do is Administrative
it's an administrative Amendment to the
book because once once we approve this
the legislative language is going to be
drafted and that'll be put that'll be
Bill include the book well which will
proc conclude the book
so what what it does say it said 10-year
plan Improvement plan the legisl here
adopts the plan known as state of New
Hampshire 10year Improvement plan 2025
to 34 submitted by the governor to the
legislature pursuant to the RSA and
encourages expenditure implementation of
the project shown
therein so if that's the case then the
governor's plan does not the the book
from the governors doesn't doesn't have
these changes in it so I would assume
that all of these changes would have to
be an amendment to the bill and I think
in the previous copy we saw the verbiage
to the bill and then amendments and it
would list a project and the change
after it and it would be a it was about
a Page worth of just project names and
and changes that were amended are we
comfortable with
that all right thank you uh why don't we
we'd had a discussion just previous you
wanted to speak in groups on on these
projects or individually how would you
like to handle that sir so I I'll talk
in gener generalities if you have
specific questions you want to talk
about uh just let me know so in the
slides I'm sorry represent I didn't see
you had a
question thank you Mr chairman um as as
far as this amendments concerned in
generalities that have you you have
recommended projects removals and then
updates because the dollars you have
more accurate dollars to put into it um
if my memory serves me
correct this reflect
projects that have not been applied for
for a
grant so if you take one of these
projects and apply for a grant for it
and get grant money does that mean you
have to have another amendment to do
something different because the money
has been
allocated no I
I I guess I'm confused because I would
say no I I mean we would be usually when
you get a grant you have a fully funded
project and you're taking grant money
and swapping out for f regular for
different federal funds so there's isn't
a change in in dollar value it's a
change of funding source so I would say
no but let me let me try to explain a
little bit about what this is and and
and where these come from so you
remember we we sort of talked about it
last week at the at at the public
hearing was um we we we take a snapshot
of the 10-year plan back in
June and we take that snapshot and we
use that as as the book because we can't
track all the changes that happened in
the last six months on projects we we
actively working on them they you know
projects are changing projects are
advancing projects are being constructed
and to keep track of them in this book
would be very painful and very hard it
would be you know five people doing this
all day long so what we do is we take a
snapshot of of the book and we bring
that forward and we move it into gasset
in Governor's phase we make some changes
gasset said make changes to
this we make changes to the governor's
face now the governor has proposed
changes those are not reflected in the
book but they were just a handful of
changes but in real life for the last
six months we've been working on a lot
of projects and advancing projects and
moving projects this list is what's
happened to the 10-year plan in those
last six or nine months since we took
that snapshot so these are the changes
that we recommend that to to basically
reflect real life of of what needs to be
changed in the 10e plan to re reflect
where these projects are now so the the
first first projects on the list now
these should be the same if not very
similar to the slides in the project so
I'm going to just refer to the sheet so
the very top of the sheet there's four
projects Claremont London area and two
Northampton those projects were not
shown in the 10-year plan because they
were going to be constructed in all
their funding spent in
2024 10e plan starts in 2025 so they
wouldn't appear these four projects due
to delays um and and being able to
advertise the project have moved from 24
into
25 so some component either the entire
project or or half of the project has
moved into 2025 that means that project
needs to be added into the 10-year plan
because it's shown in in in the first
year of the 10-year plan so these four
projects are simply these projects moved
they weren't shown in the 10-year plan
now they are in the 10year
plan so the the next group of projects
and I I will say these are projects over
a million dollars this list would get
quite long in this next section um or
I'm sorry in in a future section uh if
they're under a million dollars because
there's a lot
of Penny changes so I'll call them
Pocket Change changes these are major
changes to this to the 10-year plan so
the next group of projects are
recommended projects to withdraw so from
Gastown down to Waterville
Valley most of these projects that
you'll see are LPA
projects um they were withdrawn by the
community uh at at their request so in
in some components give you an example
um project was removed because it
entered the entered as a
a rehabilitation of the bridge at a
certain dollar value and come to find
out it needs to be replaced the
community couldn't afford the larger
dollar value to replace the bridge so
they don't want to do the project
they're going to withdraw the project
and in some cases um
like uh Manchester hooks it we advance
the project um there's a project
in I yeah could I bring your attention
into that project 41580 in molteno I
know there's several projects so just
that part was taken out and and
reallocated to a different different
priority a different priority in
molenberg yes okay thank you so th all
those projects are shown as being
withdrawn um I will say that there are
two that are showing Advanced so
Manchester hooks it the second project
and then the Salem project um both of
those uh projects were advanced in the
10-year plan so not what WR so we we
were able to do them faster so
Manchester hooks it is um five Bridges
Rehabilitation bridges on um
i93 um there's these are the Northbound
Bridges if you travel that way for the
last two years you've been in the Mayhem
of traffic control on the southbound
Bridges um we're now doing those same
five bridges on the on the Northbound
side we are able to advance those
because the bridges on the southbound
side were completed earlier so we could
Advance these and do these right away
sooner than
expected so that's that grouping of
projects now the next group that starts
at the bottom of the page um well let me
let me go back to to the Red
List yes
thank you maybe just for my okay so in
this second section if it's an advanced
project which is the Manchester hookset
and Salem correct they are in they're in
a plan yes not
necessarily they are in this one they
should be in that plan okay and and all
we did was we moved them up okay the
others that Clearly say removed or have
a withdrawn in them
okay I'm sorry let me let me correct
that so they were Advanced from 25 into
24 which means they'll be REM they're
they won't show up in the 10-year plan
I'm
sorry okay follow not to confuse you
totally but they were in the project by
moving them back we moved them ahead
forward so they would have been in the
10year plan they show up in 2025 in the
first year of the 10e plan what we were
able to do is actually construct them
sooner Advance them into
2024 so they don't appear in the 10-year
plan anymore they're done right they're
done done they will be done okay yes all
right thank you I was lost in jumbo
thank you represent
bone just so I get this straight so
basically you've saved all this money
that's why so from the 10 from the
10year plan that you're proposing you
would have had to spend this money but
because you've already finished these
projects that's a savings or we didn't
build or we or we removed them yes so
you get $96 million on on
bridges that are in this section right
here so that's it's not like you're
saying we're not going to do those you
say you've already right you're working
on those and they'll be done for 25
before 25 so let me so there is a a
correction so let me the the Statewide
red listed Bridges $96 million
that was a
placeholder project in
200 32 33 and 34 we knew we were going
to spend money on red listed Bridges we
didn't know which ones but we had set
aside a placeholder project what you'll
see is the very first project in the
next section is Bo
conquered which happens to be under
construction in in those years um that
project is large the largest project in
the 10-year plan $500 million total um
it's going to take a number of years it
involves 31 Bridges seven of them are
red listed um six
interchanges miles of Road um with a
butload of traffic in the middle so it's
very complicated what we plan to do is
we took that that money that was
allocated the $96 million that was as a
placeholder to replace red listed
bridges in the future and put them uh
towards Bo conquered to replace those
seven red listed Bridges so the money
you saved in the second section is
actually going to be spent U plus some
in the next section because the next
section are changes in really in dollar
values to projects in the 10-year plan
followup so could you just say that so
you said that you're there's seven
projects that were
Seven Bridges Seven Bridges correct how
much was the value of those seven
projects added
up well so we we haven't figured that
out just quite yet um
but it the idea is that 31 Bridges seven
of them are red listed um the idea would
be is it's about 90 we put the $96
million into those
bridges it's a work in progress yes we
it's it's because the project is so far
out we haven't gotten to the point where
we've
separated all those bridges all those
interchanges all those projects into
into uh sections we're not going to
build $500 million at once we know that
we're probably going to have 10 or so
projects that come out of it we haven't
divvied them up
yet so it's it that you know we're just
at the point where we've figured out a
selected alternative
and going to a public hearing next year
once we figure out what we're actually
building then we'll figure out how we're
going to build it and separate that out
but the idea would be is that that that
red listed Bridge money was going to go
into Bo conquered to fund those
bridges thank
you further question please continue all
right so the the bottom section are
changes and updates so um projects
removed in the second section was $111
million um the the the funding
added uh due to these changes on the
bottom of the first sheet and on the
second sheet is $154 million so your
assumption that yes we removed projects
we had money left over all went to fund
these projects that we now added money
to so um the the project starting at BO
conquered and weaving down to Portsmouth
were uh changes in costs due to increase
in cost for those projects um in some
cases depending on the size of the
project I'll use an example Manchester
those are the three Manchester projects
on the on the second page are exit six
and seven uh total project value is is
upwards of $200
million um you you tweak that a year and
you add 3.7% inflation to a year and
you've got this money so some of this is
just tweaking the scheduling of a
project adds inflation to that project
so um some of these projects were uh
updated in cost based upon actual
estimates and others were adjusting for
inflation uh due to schedule
changes and then um finally the last the
last project on the list is an
administrative correction which adds the
New Castle Ry Causeway project back into
the 10-year plan which as we noted was a
mistake so the total change in value of
this change overall is um $55
million needed to to do
this so
that I I just mentioned the total
because that's how the numbers add up
some projects were removed more projects
were changed and increased in value we
still have a constraint 10-year plan
that absorbs and distributes that $55
million so that it there isn't a change
but that's those are the changes that
have happened in the 10-year plan to
bring us up to
date questions of the
committee yes representive
edar uh thank you Mr
chair you've done a lot of work here
given us different lists and things I
just want to go back to one of the other
ones that that came out when you handed
out the excuse me when you handed out
out the information uh to was a couple
days ago and that is that there were
several projects on here I'm trying to
find them on your final list of
amendments or recom or
recommendations and of course um first
thing I was going to ask you about was
the was on page 30 uh is the Hampton
Branch rail trail it says various that
means various projects there there's
three of them in there now which which
you've uh which you already provided but
it added a 2 and A5 million to do more
work on one section and like 1.5 in
another um was that put some other place
or did you decide just when you're doing
all of the money work that we couldn't
do it now add that in now or no so these
were changes from the governor's phase
so the governor requested these changes
what he requested was he removed a lot
of the EV projects on the
top um of the list so the list is what
we handed out last time
um there were a number of e EV projects
that he wanted to be removed as well as
a Portmouth U multi-use path project and
what he asked us to do was take that
those funds and add um I believe it
works out to
be
three2 and A5 million do to the Hampton
Branch rail trail projects as a whole so
there's three project s left to right to
to do that to do that work and so what
we did is we distributed that $25
million amongst those three projects
some of them were underfunded um and so
that's where that money came
from follow up please in the book yeah
we want to find out so it's added into
the book The those figures the 2.5
million and then the 600,000 and another
1.5 is is now in the book so I believe
what we did for that was those projects
already existed in the book but if you
look in the comments there should be a
comment that says there is this much
money added in for this project got your
book in front of you Mike yeah I got it
read here but uh page 195 under
CBR yeah on your little blur it says C
Brook 42609
350k and on page 195 under the comments
it says add 350k
to cover unfunded costs for the Hampton
Beach rail
trail Y and so on the Hampton North or
Hampton Falls project on page 85 there's
a comment that says add 1.5 million to
cover unfunded cost for the Hampton
Branch rail trail so we added those
comments in we didn't have time to
really change the numbers but we wanted
to make sure that comment was added and
captured and further are you satisfied
represent edar oh I was just trying to
find the last one the H the Hampton one
the 2.5 but
um5 and
86 86
okay
page page 85 Hampton Hampton Falls on
the
bottom that adds 1.5 million MH and then
on the next
page Hampton Port Hampton
Portsmouth add 650,000
okay so all that total is uh 2 2.5
million okay it should
okay thank you that that's that I do
have another question thank you thank
you um right below that they have is
FTA
um five 339 and 5310 and a new project
are all of those also in the book they
should be in the book yes so under the
the FTA projects are shown as they're an
alphabetical order under FTA
5339 I believe no or are they
programmatics programmatics in the very
back of the
book yeah you don't have to find it
right now but you're telling me that
those are in the book same exact wording
um I believe as they're shown as
comments
okay very good thank you very much uh
represent Jack uh so having looked at
last year's last time's committee
Amendment doesn't have anything like
this level of detail in it so my current
understanding of the process is the book
continues to be a moving Target up until
the time it passes the
legislature and we produce the final
version of the book the book is a moving
Target up until we erase the word Draft
when it finally passes the legislature
and that and the bill goes to the
governor to be
signed
correct okay any further
questions oh I'm I apologize uh R
Newman I don't know if it would be
helpful or to labor intensive but
following on what representative Edgar's
uh questions were would it be useful for
the whole bunch of us to know what page
these things are on um I don't know if
that's an easy because you all know
where they go right away I don't know if
people are interested in can look them
up after I I appreciate the question but
I I think it was more specific to uh
remar's project and I from going through
that level of detail I feel well assured
that those those changes have been made
in
there okay further
questions okay so that that takes care
of that takes care of the Department's
requests the changes that need to be
done the
um no questions okay so I I have two two
other items to discuss um and I
recognize uh representative
Abbott yes thank you Mr chairman
um what I'm offering is an
amendment
and what it basically has to do is the
maintenance of Continental Boulevard in
maraman and what the Amendment states is
that the Department of Transportation
shall not be responsible for
maintainance of Continental Boulevard in
the town of
marac and the effective date shall be it
will take effect on July 1st
2026 the reason for this amendment is
even though this is a Town Road the
Department of Transportation has been
responsible for maintenance of
Continental
Boulevard at a cost of um $80,000 a year
and that does not include any new
restrictions on the amount of salt to be
used for for snow clearing and the last
time time um that the Continental
Boulevard was repaved repaved was in
2017 so it's about due um
2025 I the math is
right and the cost of of the Lost of
revenue from elimination of the toll WS
at exits 12 11 and 10 is $1.7
million uh to the uh Turnpike system and
the cost to remove the three toll booths
is 1.9 million that's what it costs to
take them
out to cost to full remove fully remove
remnants of ramp to tunnels building
demolition ramp
reconstruction is $4
million um so I think if this is going
to be a road in the town of miramac and
the town is going to receive the um
um the uh benefits of the business the
property tax on the business located
along Continental Boulevard that they
should be responsible for the
maintainance of this road
um and I can't think of any other
examples that we have where the doot is
responsible for the maintenance of town
roads uh anywhere else in uh New
Hampshire thank you
representative um questions questions of
the committee
or so for some some background for
committee
members um history lesson history lesson
and um and I'll take uh further after my
comments um we
had nearly all the 20 years I've been
around since 2002 there's always maych
had always had a
conversation about wanting to remove
tolls but um
it and it was
to FL back up they there were
improvements that were needed to be made
to the turnpike system and to make those
improvements it would involve
tolling um for
that and it was under those terms the
legislature appropriated the money and
the roads were
built there was a constant effort after
that time that from I don't know whether
it would be the town of marac or
surrounding towns it they're that the
fee to build that should have been paid
back and that it was a burden now to
their
town
the the um and M representative Abbott
has highlighted some of some of the
items of the cost that it it cost a
Turnpike system between revenue of what
those uh tolls were and um you know
nearly $4 million in the end to remove
all of that that it left us with a
section of road which was Continental
Boulevard that we said when when all of
this was done it was the position I
believe of the department and and and we
confirmed it as as a position a policy
out of this committee that we were no
longer going to pay for the maintenance
we had already paid to resurface it and
it left here as not being part of the 10
plan was being removed but at some time
during the process of two years ago
Committee of conference um it came back
in and I believe the intent of this is
to pull it back out again do you want to
add more to that um no other than let R
and Mills go first actually even
predating the the 20e mark the the tolls
and everything was built at the request
of the of marac they had they had
digital equipment coming
in okay thank you I'm being I'm being
corrected to put my microphone on they
had the digital equipment coming back in
and in order to accommodate all the
traffic going to that way uh and this
used to be this used to be a a a
practice for all new for all new uh
Representatives come in when when you
went to your first day of practice on on
on build bills and things this used to
be something that was argued because it
it had been so historic there were the
the town had approached the town
managers the police everybody begged the
legislature to put in these ex extend
the uh Turnpike to it so they did and uh
put in the tolls and everything went
fairly normal up until digital shut down
there and at that point in time the town
felt
that they had paid enough that they'
paid the bond and everything else and
wanted all the tolls removed as part of
that original agreement when Continental
Boulevard was in there the state had and
just where you guys can correct me the
state had put in salt sheds the state
had put in a little mini um what what
whatever you call it a maintenance yard
or something like that and agreed to
maintain Continental
Boulevard when when all the tolls went
away and they asked everything to be
removed this committee attempted to give
the town back Continental Boulevard and
uh we were
in agreement to do that and it and it
did get overturned at a at a higher
level so that's my background with itcl
thank you Mr chairman and I've been on
this committee basically all but one
term since 1992 and when I first came to
the very first year there was a bill in
put by the marac representatives to deal
to remove all the
tolls and uh so they solve the problem
the problem is it was pointed out if we
removed all the polls there'd be at
least a a a 10 a 10 cent hike in the gas
tax to pay for removal of the tolls but
they've been consistent and and I was
I've seen documentation it was before I
came to the committee in the late 80s
that the town of at least the town of
Mer their leaders were willing to pay
for the exit ramp tolls and I'm I'm I I
guess it's a controversial issue but in
the documentation the town leaders
wanted were willing to have the
residents pay uh for the improvements to
attract digital equipment at the time by
installing these uh uh I'm sorry ramp
TOS so it's been a constant issue and it
was you know ever since the 90s it uh
has come before our committee and the in
N 2014 as part of a deal to raise the
gas tax uh then chairman Campbell worked
with then Senate President Peter bragon
who represented March I believe and they
removed one of the tolls um and then I
think this the rest one of them was when
I was Sher uh then go then oh excuse me
Governor sonunu working with the late
dick hinch and then executive counselor
Deb pnck heli cut a deal which I wasn't
informed about until after it was
publicly announced and John Graham who's
the ranking Republican wasn't too happy
we weren't even inform formed I would
have loved to gone on to that council
meeting and I would have probably at
least spoken my mind probably wouldn't
have won but it was approved on a 4 to1
vote uh you know with only one counselor
my counselor then Mike cryan's
supporting it but it's not real partisan
issue I understand if you live in marac
you're probably in favor of eliminating
the tolls but I I have to balance it the
public you know between uh between the
obligations of the town of marac and the
state and I I don't know I think it's
reasonable to turn it back to town
because we've eliminated I believe all
the tolls now so the town of marac they
should be very happy for that but that's
that's my opinion thank
you thank you further
comment yes please representative well
thank you Mr chairman since I am the
evil redheaded stepchild sitting over
here from Mar I would not say
that representative I apologize for the
clarification but um
two years ago I was the only person that
that that did vote that did vote against
this and I gave the speech on the floor
against and I still stand by the
argument you know Exit 12 was removed
and the what was given back was a four
increase in the gas tax so there was
there was some trade-off the removal of
the tolls got a got a 4 Cent bump on the
gas tax that's number one number two we
were able to document that Exit 11 was
Was Not only was not only
pay you know paid off it was actually
costing the dot they were paying more
money out in maintenance to manage Exit
11 than what it was actually bringing in
so so the the foundation behind those
two the removal of two two of those
particular toll boots combined with the
fact that we were able to show that the
bonds were paid off at the time
Justified the removal of those
particular tolls so that's the other
thing the the third thing is the way
that the way that I read the amendment
is is you're beaking the town of road
that we have absolutely no idea what
condition the road is in we're getting
the road as is so conceivably something
could happen within the next within a
year or two that would require an
additional cost for the town to absorb
to be able to dig up and repair what
needs to be done to whatever to whatever
it needs to be done to that particular
stretch of roadway so accepting
something Prima fascia as is just
doesn't sit with me and then the last
thing that I would point out is you know
the road
does does nashwa and pelum and Hudson a
tremendous favor by by gearing any any
traffic driving westbound that wants to
go north they're avoiding exit they're
avoiding exit hate because now they can
go north on Continental Boulevard and
they can utilize Exit 11 to be able to
travel North it's that it's that simple
it's it's it's it's an ancillary Feld
road that provide that provides a Regal
artery to people that live in the
Southern and West excuse me southern and
western part of of Hillsboro County that
are looking to go north onto 93 so
because of the regional perspective that
the road Prov provides provides should
should require a higher level of care
and maintenance that the state has been
able to provide for a certain period of
time so this there's the regional
balance that the road brings so those
are the reasons why you know and and I
app appreciate my my good friend from
cheser County I really do um but those
are the reasons why I I disagree with
this amendment because you it's it's
it's it's ping a road upon a town that
has no idea has no idea with what
they're getting and in anecdotally tell
you right now that the town fathers if
they got it they'll close it they pretty
much have said to me if we get it we'll
close it and I'm not sure that that's
going to
do the S the Southern Tier of Hillsboro
County in any favor by clo closing a
major roadway that not that not just
feeds the northern part of New Hampshire
probably also feeds um Manchester Boston
Regional Airport so there's that
particular concern to factor in as well
so anyway I appreciate the opportunity
thank you representative Mr chairman
repres CLE uh yes a question and maybe
to the department in and I know
representative boy just raised some
concerns about the condition of the road
does the department or has the
department inspected the Continental
Boulevard lately and if they've
inspected what sort of condition is the
RO thank you for the question I have no
reason to believe that there is anything
eminently or immediately wrong with
Continental Boulevard that that road is
in good shape by um all information that
I have okay all right thank thank you
and um I guess I guess my question would
be if we had a long discussion this
morning on um
resurfacing of Highways and I believe u
i can't remember what year previous that
that was resurfaced 2017 perhaps so um
it would seem that there is going to be
a cost if the state were to continue on
of some factor of 1.7 million whatever
that might be and it would seem to me
that the detriment to the town or
whatever form of government is there
that to maintain that road they If This
Were to pass that would be the cost to
keep that road uh that road to the
standard it is right
now so do I understand you to suggest
that as part of this as part of turning
Continental Boulevard over to the town
that this committee may require the
department to resurface the road prior
to that thank you for that clar
ification my point is no my I I was I
was making a u a comment that the road
is my understanding of good quality at
this point in time and that the state
had put a resurfacing on it in
2017 my point was only that uh when the
good representative had brought the
point we don't know what condition this
is I would say on the surface that they
would have to anticipate to keep it in
the level of surface it is at some point
in the number of years they'd have to
resurface it where if we were to hold on
to this we as the state are going to
have to incur that
cost that's that's all I agree with that
the the
um I'll speak in
generalities my my concern with our
continued care of this road is I
understand that we have we have other
lsrs that are coming forward with a
displeasure of a water quality
issue and asking uh um do if it were to
come through here that to uh mandate a
lesser amount of salt and and my concern
is that this could let's let's say the
state were to hold on to this and then
we then we have to expend more money to
regulate salt
content at what point this I
guess would you
believe that the state could be
subjected to more and more mandates
going
forward on a road that we
own there's no need to answer that and I
apologize I don't typically allow that
to happen the chairman just went there
so um did did would they uh would the
department care to weigh in at all on
the amendment
want me
to i i c I certainly understand the the
the the the the committee's position um
I think from the Department's
perspective we reconciled ourselves to
the existing conditions two years ago
when when when when when uh a similar
amendment was was was Was Defeated
so you know with that said you know
we're reconciled to to continue
maintaining it uh it's it's it's our de
facto as part of the system it had been
debated previously that said it
certainly the Committees and the
legislator's uh prerogative all the all
the points you made make were points
that that that
um we tried to make several years ago
when um when the um when the when the
tolls were eliminated ated
so yes repres Bor
please not being extremely familiar with
this road that y'all are talking about
but being on a Town Council uh what
benefit does it give marac to take
control of the road out of the hands of
the state I don't understand what
benefit there is there there if I could
there there is no benefit for the town
to take that over it was our point that
it was when we when we
relinquished the Turnpike tolls booths
and made all the improvements those were
all cost being born by the state and it
was a position we were going to turn it
back to the town and the town or city I
apologize I don't the town that um that
they had Lobby to a point to reverse
that position
a followup please pleas
so this is an amendment borne by Public
Works not necessarily the town and
correct so the town could perceive this
as an unfriendly amendment to them sure
they might they will
yes yes re parner please so my
understanding is that we brought this up
as an amendment to
a petition by the town of marac to
reduce or eliminate toll boots so their
benefit is that their residents don't
pay tolls where they used to and
so this was sort of quot quot that they
get a benefit pick up some
responsibility those they did eliminate
the tolls but never picked up the the
road yes follow up and then I'll come
back to I oliz thank you so no no reason
to apologize go right ahead sir is this
all written in agreement somewhere that
if we got rid of the tolls we would turn
the road over to them or was this just
people talking and presumptions on a lot
of different
people's thoughts it was the position if
I could and please correct me it was a
position of this committee that we had
done that and that we were that we were
relinquishing that section of road back
to the town because it was not connected
by a Turnpike any
longer first Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman uh following up on the history
lesson that our clerk provided yes it is
true that digital equipment did uh close
that facility it wasn't too long after
that that Fidelity opened uh a facility
at that location and I would assume that
it's still open that it has about I I
did work there at the time uh I would
assume it has about the same number of
employees that it had then which is
probably over a thousand uh it surprises
me to hear that the town would close a
road that is the only access to that
plant for over a thousand people I
wonder how they're going to get to work
itself as an industrial
drive thank
you yes um I would um see there's quite
a bit of discussion here I would like to
recess for 10 minutes I'm gonna permit
the two parties to caucus and my and my
thought is to come back straw pull this
and other amendments and so that we can
depending on how we go we will then uh
send it in working with the
Department uh to um to have the final
draft done and um so why don't we do
that okay where do should the Democrats
C this well we've been taking the small
room and giving you the big room all
right so you want to continue with that
we we'll go we'll we'll go we'll go the
small room okay good okay thank you Mr
chairman for Democrats meet in the big
room like the Republicans will meet the
small Chairman's
office thank you
right
e
e e
all right well let's uh return back to
um work session here the
um I would like to move to a position
that we could possibly get this uh final
amendments
drafted and we have done it in the
past we have in the past P done a straw
poll to see how the committee feels and
then we and then we send it off to Los
for
drafting um once everyone's had a chance
to uh see it read
it um we will then you know take it up
as as an official um vote of the
committee so what I would like to start
with is a straw
poll
um on the
amendments um the project amendments
brought brought by the uh Department
published on the front and the back of
this page
here and I think we've fully is is there
any further discussion on on the what's
contained in here by the committee yes
please Mr chair I think that's my copy
thank you Mr chairman and I apologize
that the answer is some place but what
if with these amendments what's the
bottom line how much money how much
money are we spending on the 10year plan
addition well no I see that $55 million
it's on this with the what is the bottom
line on on the 10e plan would the
department know that isn't in the
neighborhood of$ 225 $250 million
typically yes
total five billion for
10 per year so it's it's a billion
dollars over the next two
years then then then this it's that 55
I'm sorry 50 5 million on top of that
500 million so it's about 10%
increase what you're asking for with
this amendment
here this is thank you for that
clarification thank you Mr any any
further questions yes please represent
fuler kazinski raised a question on
Newcastle uh New Hampshire WB Causeway
doesn't have a price tag on the sheet is
that something we need
to to
they if if I remember correctly what the
department has said is this the last
project Newcastle New Hampshire 1B um it
is it is
already
included uh Kathleen would you mind
answering the question we had the
discuss or one of the department
but but it will be added back into the
10-year plan when it was inadvertently
removed any further questions before we
go to a
poll repent Mills Mr chairman I uh I
move uh for the straw poll I move a to
pass on on the do draft 10-year plan
project amendments as is thank you
second second in by
board um we will not it'll be it's a
straw poll it's not an official count if
you're in favor of the motion to include
these items as amended into the 10-year
plan raise your
hand and and it would appear to be
unanimous um second uh second item for
consideration uh is amendment uh
868 um Amendment um brought forward by
representative Abbott um which uh we
have been
discussing and it would be in in sense
ter rning the Continental
Boulevard um responsibility back to
marac any further discussion on that Mr
chair a question just to clarification
so is a stroo on representative Abbott's
Amendment as he submitted is correct no
changes or correct additions okay thank
you move the amendment or with the
amendment Mr chair excuse
me rev
pner my only concern I
certainly approve of the sentiment the
the idea behind it my only concern is
whether this is going to generate u a
floor fight on something that otherwise
would be a pretty clean clean bill and
whether that's something that we uh are
prepared to
U defend I guess that's the
question and I thank you for the comment
and the comments been brought up by
other Representatives
also uh to myself it's a fairness issue
and it it's been and if that turns out
to be the case and we were to be a
majority vote here or even a stronger
vote than that then that would be the
hill I would climb for this
committee further
question uh thank you Mr chairman uh
after we vote on this can we still
discuss the whole thing maybe a change
to this or amendment to Amendment okay
very good thank you
okay then Mr chair I will move ought to
pass on representative Abbot Abbott's
bill
as
presented okay I'll second that for so
we can move so we've had plenty of
discussion if you're in favor draw a
poll again of including this amendment
into the 10-year plan signify by raising
your hand
you have a number and if you're
opposed one thank
you
representative uh thank you Mr chair um
I raised my hand uh just a couple
seconds ago I would raise it even higher
if we would uh consider um possibly uh
turning over the
uh the
boulevard after we pave
it thank
you okay so if I if I understand a
future amendment that You' like
considered would be that we would stay
with the committee position of um
turning turning the road back over to
the the town but you saying in doing so
only after the state had completed a
repaving of that of that
road uh yes Mr chairman by by
okay let's see let's see what the
U favor of the committee is does
everyone understand the possible
amendment to
this that we would still be turning it
over but uh the suggestion is that we
wouldn't turn it over until the uh until
the department had repave the road one
more time and by the year
2026 everyone understand
that yes the question would be is the
money already
funded for this or this new money to be
added
would you care to answer
that I I'll ask a question of to try to
answer thank you Mr chairman and that is
i' would like to ask if in fact that by
2026 that money would already be
included in some of the 10-year plan
projects that are shown seeing we're
told that about every eight years or so
we we repay that it this would be on the
list by then thank you
so this would be a Turnpike funded
expenditure and the Turnpike does have
an annual Paving program um so if we had
to work this this section in we could
work it in it may come at the expense of
the mainline on the the turnpike that
typically a a higher need
thank you uh RAM
Newman yes by um uh mandating I guess
for lack of a better word that It Be
repaved by
2026 is that is that something that
everybody could guarantee I mean what if
there I don't know if things had to be
um pushed off a year or two or whatever
due to scheduling weather whatever does
that blow up the whole thing if you tie
in a date
certain I I I would answer I I don't
know the answer to that and we would ask
that question my issue with that
is
if I I think it's cleaner to say we
continue or we stop if if we were to say
that we were and this is my this is only
my opinion I'm opening it for
discussion if year 2026
conditions of of before before the
pavement could be resurfaced there was
even more work that was needed to bring
the road in compliance or rather more
maintenance that needed to be done then
I think it would be easy enough for the
city to argue that that work should also
be included into it so I'm I'm afraid if
we were to amend it to
resurfacing by
2026 and we know that it was 1.6 million
when we did it in
2017 that we know that in today's
dollars it's going to be well over $2
million I'm afraid what else would have
to be done to that road before we could
resurface it so I'm I'm at the pleasure
of this committee but I I won't be uh
voting for that we're either going to do
it or we're not going
to any further discussion
so if you're favor of drafting another
committee amendment that would uh would
change the uh Abid amendment that was
brought forward uh to uh now say that
the department would
resurface um the length of this road uh
no later than
2026 if you're in favor of that raise
your hand
two three four okay and if you're
opposed
okay
so did we take a count on the other way
there were three votes I think in favor
of Mike Ed amendment I
okay four okay I think it's four okay
still de 12
against 4 to 12
so um so we we have we have Direction on
the straw pole for that and we'll we'll
draft with this this is all subject to
the final
vote uh the last is I propose putting an
amendment um which uh discusses the um
title Salvage rail to offset Trail
construction and um there was a bill
through this committee and there was
discussion through this
today that the department has a position
presently that if rail is removed when
trails are being built that that um that
that rail remains in the possession of
the
department um my proposal is that any
and all rail removed from the rail uh
specific from Center Osby moltonville
road to Silver Lake
1341 which is what the bill we brought
through forward shall be salvaged either
as relay rail or steel Sal for it steel
salvage value the revenue generated
shall be re be used to remove the rail
in the corridor for trail
construction the department my
understanding has a policy that covers
all of the rail that they are in
possession of this is this is a half of
Corridor
19 uh that's the uh excuse me it's the a
it's the Conway Branch the trail
division calls it Corridor
19 it is only 10 10 miles of that and it
would only affect that that section of
of rail is owned by the state of New
Hampshire we took possession of it and
in the event in the future that rail
would ever come back that the state
would relinquish that property if a ra
if a trail was built on it the trail
would extinguish and be gone because
there is no right of way connected with
it so um it's a
proposal and I look it more as a pilot
project does it work for the department
or not but it just says if this project
moves forward that that salvage value
can be used and it's our understanding
that that rail does not have
um value for transported Freight at this
time yes suggest that not just talk
about the rail but Rail and other you
know tie plates
Fasteners switches signals I I would
imagine signals and that sort of word we
could add that would include all of that
but I will I'll consider that if that's
what thought is yeah any further
questions
yes
please
Russ who would take possession of the
money from the
Salvage it it the the intent is that
that there there would have to be a
group that would be formed to to
construct the rail
trail and they the money would be to
remove the rail and if there was more
money than that I I don't know that
there would be more money oh so that's
like a private organization or yes it
something Incorporated through the
town any further
questions so if um if you are in favor
of the amendment um to be written which
would be included in here which would
only be for this one section of rail 10
miles uh signify a raising your
hand and if you're
opposed carries your Nas so we will
will'll draft I will work with the
department and draft one Amendment and
if we're fortunate enough to have this
all pulled together by
Friday um we will have that discussion
and if it doesn't if it can't come
together that quickly it's not my intent
to bring this committee back next week
when the when we're it would be the
following
week okay any further B yes rep Jack uh
scheduling question if as is predicted
we go very very late tomorrow would we
still uh plan on meeting on Friday
morning we we're on we're on the
schedule at this point so I would we
look at if the amendment is would we
look at answer Friday literally that's
all we be doing on right it's voting on
amends we could uh we could we could
make that announcement on the floor
because it's already in the calendar so
I think I think we could make the
announcement on the
floor tomorrow representative Jack in
the event that we and as represent Mill
says if the amendment's not ready then
we could do
that um and then push off
to maybe the Tuesday the week after
that we we'll come up with some dates
tomorrow that we can talk about during
session not next Tuesday it' be the
following week okay because we're on
there is a legisl way a break I mean
it's up to committees decide where they
want to meet but basically it's for the
entire okay could you take over I was
supposed to be on the third floor 10
minutes ago okay all right good thank
you Mr chair hopefully didn't miss you
all right okay all right so I think
that's it for today uh I don't think we
have anything else unless somebody wants
to add but we will be in here at uh
10:00 on Friday morning for a work
session and at 10:00
uh we will'll plan to have our executive
session uh and around that time I mean
we may have party cup but in other words
right now we're on the schedule to exact
uh House Bill 2024 at 11:00 a.m. on this
coming Friday but as I said try to right
now we'll come in 10 o'clock for a work
session okay I will yes go ahead please
commissioner
cath just before you disband I would
just like to thank everybody for their
attention I know we had a lot of
information there um and and please if
you have any questions as we go forward
re Reach Out reach out to us directly
but um um I just wanted to say thank you
for your for your attention uh and
getting through all this information I
re we really appreciate it so thank you
okay thank you very much commissioner
cash so with that uh I will adjourn the
committee for the or I guess recess is
the proper term recess the committee for
the day thank you